foreign
good morning everyone can I welcome
everyone to miss Suffolk Midsouth sorry
mid Suffolk District Council development
control committee a
um uh I just need to run through some of
the domestic arrangements before we make
a start uh can you please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use and
please and members of the public not to
interrupt other speakers or hold
separate conversations when people are
speaking if you are attending the
meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt you may be asked to leave the
meeting
and ask everyone just to get their
mobile phones out and double check they
are switched off or on silent
um please and can I also ask you to do
the same with your computers just to
make sure the volume is turned down to
stop them pinging when the come in
we will be using e-voting for this
meeting as usual which is on modern.gov
app so please because I just asked
members to remind to remind you to stay
logged into that so we can use the actor
in the meeting
uh I'd like to remind everyone present
this meeting will be broadcast live on
the internet and we'll be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except when
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council and to the possible use
of those sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes the council
members of the public and the Press May
record film photograph or broadcast this
meeting when the public and the Press
are not lawfully excluded if you do hear
the fire alarm today please leave the
building immediately by the fire exits
and make your ways to the assembly point
at Ipswich Town Football Club
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exit at each end of the floor and
please do not enter the atrium building
which is the ground floor area and
walkways if you're in the atrium that
when the alarms are when the alarm
sounds please follow the signs of the
new Aspire exit please do not use the
lifts and use the stairs and do not
re-enter the building too it's told it's
safe to do so okay so just a few
introductions uh if that actually
haven't got any members of the public
with anyone that might be watching
online uh in mid-summer District Council
the decision to have been made by the
councilors here on my left and myself uh
in at mid-suffolk however you cannot
vote on an application you'll own Ward
and we also have Ward members who have
the opportunity to speak on applications
as well within their Ward
um okay I think we'll go straight in to
the first item on the agenda
um I'll do some quick introductions
actually because there's some faces here
that not everyone may be familiar first
of all down there we have Philip Isbell
who's the chief planning officer uh we
have uh next to that Catherine Davies
who's the sustainable travel officer
then we have Ben Chester from highways
and then we have Bradley uh heifer who's
presenting an Ian to press who's our
legal advisor on my right uh we know
Claire Philpot on my left we have Alicia
Norman and Beth Webb who keep the
meeting ticking over for us and make
sure everything runs smoothly so we'll
go straight into apologies for absence
do we have any please
counselor wellum is substituting for
councilor even Council of War boys is
substituting for Council and Matheson
councilor Morley is substituting for
Council or Passmore and councilor Heston
is substituting for councilor Humphries
thank you
so we're one member thank you okay
more pecuniary interests and other
registerable or non-registerable
interests by members
yes councilworth
um I am the county councilor for
stowmarket North which includes this
these two sites
um I think that's all I have to declare
thank you very much
no one else okay so we'll move on to the
next item any decorations of lobbying
that's the one
I I've been lobbied by various people in
respect of both applications over a long
period of time
thank you very much
any decorations of personal site visits
I'm not a site bit per se but I do use
the b113 on a very regular basis
because I walked that way and I I cycle
that way and I drive that way so I'm
very familiar with with both of these
sites and have on occasion had cause to
walk into the sides to the allotments or
up the track so over a period of time
yes I
I have visited the sides
thank you very much okay um on the
confirmation minutes as more than half
of the committee uh is substituted I've
decided to move the minutes to the next
meeting because I think it's unfair for
so many people not to have a say on them
so they'll come to the next meeting
because it's very rare for us to have so
many substitutions obviously this isn't
on a normal day for the meeting so
that's probably why
okay um do we need to receive any
notifications of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
okay
right into the first of the two
applications before us today which is
dc20
01036 Ash's Farm in Newton Road Stone
Market and are now hand them to a case
officer Bradley heifer to introduce the
application to us
thank you chair good morning
members ladies gentlemen this
application has previously been to
committee for consideration
on the 20th of July this year
um it's an outline application for 300
units
um I'll run through the presentation
again just to refresh everyone's memory
and then following on from that
we'll look at the specific reasons for
deferral at the last meeting which will
know there are four reasons or four
issues that members wanted some more
information on or more consideration of
and I'll deal with those at the end of
the the presentation
so as I say it's a an outline
application for 300 units on site Ash's
Farm Newton Road
um
the application is an outline except for
the access the main means vehicular
access uh full planning permission is
being sought at this stage
this is a wider aerial view which shows
the site in relation to the town
Stone Market
to the South and Stow Upland
to the North East
the other elements I would point out on
this drawing I saw around this plan are
the line of the A14
Trunk Road
which runs along the top of this site
this is an aerial map this shows the
extent of the site again you will note
it's bisected by Newton Road
um and also there's an area of land to
the right hand side which is the subject
of the next item of the agenda and
that's known as diapers Farm
this is a red line application drawing
site site plan the thing I think is
relevant to point out on this particular
plan is the fact that the allotment site
is edged red sorry Edge blue which means
it's under the ownership of control of
the applicant but it doesn't form part
of the planning application
uh the constraints map you'll notice a
lot of blue on the site as a substantial
amount of this part of the application
site is within a flood zone
um
the remaining area is outside the other
elements I would point out on this
drawing are the settlement boundary
which is shown there edged Brown again
you've got the road across the top and
you've also got footpaths that cross the
site plus this one and the adjacent site
diapers farm and you're also no in the
vicinity there are some grade two listed
buildings namely The Farmhouse itself
and some others others closer to the
diapers farm development
this extract is taken from the council's
development brief which was produced
subsequent to the Stow Market error
action plan the area we're talking about
under this particular application is
Zone one
um
that covers
this area of land and the site on the
opposite side of Newton Road
um the difference with the ashes Farm
application you're considering now is
that the land here is also include this
open area of land here is included
within the the application site
this is the concept plan that is also in
the council's development brief
um
to point out in relation to
um
considerations later on you'll notice
that there's an area of open space
towards the northeastern part of the
site
lower density development through the
middle higher density development and
more open space well that's the
allotments but more open space left to
this particular boundary and then you've
got the area of open space on the
opposite side and the arrow there is an
indication of the point of access
through the site
the other dotted line that's
that's worth pointing out at this stage
is the line of a spine Road link between
the two again shown
set rather than a specific detail
this is the illustrative master plan
that's submitted as part of the planning
application
which follows if I go back to that one
and then quickly go to this one it
follows in our view the the general
themes that are drawn out in the concept
plan insofar as the arrangement
of space is on the site in sapphires you
have the area of open space at the top
the light brown color you can see there
is an area of lesser or sorry less dense
development and then the darker area is
the area of what would be more dense
development
and then areas of open space
on this side and again
these two sites here being used or
utilized as open space
as part of the proposals you'd expect
there's um because of the scale of the
development there's a need to provide
Highway improvements as I said at the
start the application itself does seek
full planning permission for the
vehicular means of access which is up
here and there's various Works proposed
along
Newton Road
which I'll go into more detail in the
subsequent slides
firstly starting with the main point of
access for vehiculars sorry for car
vehicles
this is a priority Junction as you can
see and it's got
it's part of the design Footwear coming
out of the site which goes on to Newton
Road then a crossing point which carries
on to a footwear on this side of the
site there has been changes to this plan
or this proposal but I'll go
further into presentation
this is if you can remember that
crossing point which was about there
this is the remainder of that path which
comes down through the area of open land
which forms part of the application site
and then crosses over and then continues
down
and then goes back onto Newton Road
to join up with the existing provision
here
the plan that shown this work shows the
proposal to
regularize if that's the right word the
planning sorry the parking provision
that's adjacent to the
um
the allotment spaces
um you'll see there's a line of car
parking along the side of the road there
which is proposing that's a total of 18
spaces that
and also
there's a link a footpath link adjacent
to this Junction which it's proposed to
widen
this isn't a plan or this is a plan you
haven't seen before this is a
connectivity plan and this was produced
as a result of the deferral you'll note
that it's a joint plan produced by the
applicants for this application and the
applicants for the
diapers Farm proposal
and this is to demonstrate connectivity
bearing in mind that
the The Proposal on diapers Farm is a
full application which we'll be talking
about later on and this is an outline
application
so everything you see on this drawing
apart from the means of access is in
outline but I think the key point to
note even at this stage is that there is
agreement to provide the connectivity
between the two insofar as the spine
Road link between Star Upland Road
and Newton Road
and also there's an indication on that
drawing of a shared cycle footway also
following that route which is the light
green line you can see following that
following through there
and also the continuation of footpath
links having the same treatment through
both sites along the boundary there
and the maintenance obviously of the
footpath links that are shown the other
thing that is shown on this is the link
through to stomach and road at the
bottom using the existing line the the
prowl at that point so there'd be a link
through the site up to there would still
be respected as part of the the public
right-of-way Network
so if I go back to that the um the other
thing which I'll talk about again but I
will show you because the plan is up is
that whereas under the previous
iteration of this um of the drawings for
Ashley's Farm there was a footpath
proposal
that was going to link from here
down through the open space and back
onto Newton Road
the applicants for the ashes Farm
proposal have agreed that this would now
take the form of shared footway cycleway
from that point
to that point there so that's a change
that's happened since the consideration
of the planning application originally
some photographs of the surrounding site
this is the approach the site from the
north you see the bridge containing the
A14
along Stone sorry along Newton Road this
is the approach leading up to the site
entrance
and the approximate position of the site
entrance itself
that's one of the areas of open space
which would remain as is
that's the one of the spaces sorry
that's one here is that's also covered
by the the flood zone constraint which I
spoke about earlier
um that's another shot
this is the access where where a Newton
Road and Spring Road join
um and the footpath that is now proposed
to be a footway cycle weight will come
along the back
and join
across here into a new provision at this
point
so that that's the change at that
Junction
That's A View From the the main road up
to all looking along Spring Row
um and as I said previously with the
introduction of the footway cycleway
along this point that would allow
cyclists to continue down this route
into town which would avoid the use of
the Newton Road Stowe Upland Road
Junction at the bottom which
as members are aware is a is a well used
and quite an unfriendly environment for
cyclists so in terms of um
an alternative route that would offer an
alternative as far as officers are
concerned
that's looking at the um up towards the
the site access
one of the elements that would be
required as part of this would be an
extension of 30 mile an hour speed limit
so that those two signs there which are
the Restriction signs would be moved
further north towards the um
a bridge
that's a shot of The Farmhouse which is
is listed itself
and again looking down the road
this is the narrower part of Newton Road
as you approach or get nearer to the
town do I've mentioned before with the
existing footpath provision
and that's the edge of the allotments
and you can see
along there the existing parking
provision and that would be remodeled as
part of the proposals one element that
was mentioned at the last meeting was
status and use of
this
line here it's private
at the last meeting I advise that that
is within the red line and that was
wrong
was incorrect an apologies for the um
the misinformation the red line
actually ends at this point here so the
applicant has no
control ownership or control of that
access
clarify that particular point
this is viewed across the site itself um
taken a while ago but clearly you can
see it's um agricultural former
agricultural land
that was fellow at the time I took those
photographs
one of the noticeable things in top
ographically is the fall that you get
which is roughly from the north to south
although it's it's a bit more nuanced
than that so the highest part of the
site is towards the um
the
Trunk Road which is which will be along
the top of the boundary there
there's further views this is the access
sorry this is the junction Newton Road
Stow Upland Road
um and as part of the proposals this is
the widened
of pathway which um which would be
improved and as I say in terms of the um
the alternative means of or the
alternative shared cycle route
and that would at least encourage
cyclists to use an alternative route and
not have to use that particular Junction
when trying to access the town by cycle
or Town Center this is the a120 B triple
one five Junction
um this is in Stow Upland but that is
the key Junction that would require
Improvement as part of
this planning application and the
application at diapers
and members will have noted from my
consultation sorry from my
application
report that there is a membrane
memorandum of understanding between the
Developers
in order to provide that Junction
Improvement
as part of the section 106 and a
condition that would be imposed on the
planning
Commission
and that is another view of the access
if I just quickly turn to
yep so the last application or the
meeting when this application was last
considered it was deferred for four
reasons
um and they're numbered in the um on
page 20 of the agenda
um
if I work through the issues that um I
hope you've had a chance to read the the
report but if I just quickly go through
the the issues I think the first thing
to point out is that
sorry not page 20. I do apologize
members it's page 37.
um
the first thing I should point out is
following the meeting there's a joint
statement has been produced by both
applicants which you've had hoped have
had a chance to read but basically
assures that there would be joint
working with regard to the two sites
bearing in mind that they're under
separate ownerships and their separate
proposals and it
um inherent on on trying to get
um
a scheme that's that covers the whole
development in essence and and I think
that that is the developers showing to
the council that they are understand
that situation the fact that there's
necessary improvements uh required to
the junction and the need for
connectivity
um and that sets that out the the
developers positioning in that respect
um in in return in relation to issue
number one the appropriateness of cycle
cycling active travel
um I did touch on some of the issues
there
um
there is the connectivity plan which you
will have seen which explains how the
two the two sites link notwithstanding
the fact that one is outlined and one is
full
um there's the proposal to include The
Pedestrian and cycle path as part of the
spine road which again is is shown on
the connectivity plan
um and there's
the issue of including the or creating
the shared cycle path footpath as you
come out of the entrance on onto Newton
Road
um which again are improvements
um and the link through to the existing
prowl at the bottom of style Upland Road
which is going to be discussed as part
of the um the diapers Farm application
um
in terms of issue number two
um I think one of the points that came
out of the meeting last time was whether
the
examination if that's the right word of
the impacted Junctions locally
was robust enough whether that would
actually as I'd actually been undertaken
because it was felt that the experience
of driving around locally doesn't match
what was being said
in the um the assessments
we've gone back to the highway Authority
just to clarify at that particular point
and they've again reiterated as far as
they're concerned they've looked at the
um the relevant assessments and they do
believe that they are a robust
assessment of the overall impact the
other thing that we've received
subsequent to the first meeting is an
analysis document of all the impacted
Junctions that were agreed with the
highway Authority
and the assessment of each of those
Junctions which
culminated in the identified 1120 treble
one five Junction
um being the one that would be over
capacity and the one that requires the
Improvement and hence the agreement
that's been reached in relation to that
through the memorandum of understanding
and also to be secured through section
106 and the planning conditions
the other thing I think that came out of
um members concerns in relation to
access was the single point of access
issue
there was concerned about that
notwithstanding the fact that eventually
this site could link through to the
other end through diapers Farm if you
look at it as a standalone application
there is only a single point of access
um
as you'll have seen the highway
Authority are
content with that approach
on the basis of the width of the access
that's being provided
because it's been a 7.3 wide 7.3 meter
wide access
in their view notwithstanding any work
so it may be taking place with drainage
or whatever you can still get past so
there will be access available
through that particular
proposed access point
and I'm advised that this form of access
or the single access point of that width
has been used elsewhere in the
um in terms of the open appropriateness
of open space provision
um the plans that were shown previously
in my presentation in relation to the um
or the development brief that was
produced by the county
um do show the provision of open space
towards a stop at the top of the site
which is the highest part of the site
and that was a response to the
um
the visual analysis that took place at
that time when the brief was undertaken
um and the
um illustrative plan that you have
before you does replicate that so the
location of the open space matches the
open space that's that's shown on that
plan
um and I think the other thing bearing
in mind the original allocation was for
400 in the sap
um Stone market area action plan
um this has been uplifted through the
the development brief
process and there will be undoubtedly a
denser form of development being
provided on the site than you would get
with 400 units so that would impact on
open space provision generally
um but I think in terms of the way the
the open space is arranged it's still
seeking to replicate the open space
Arrangement that was shown at the time
of the development brief
um lastly in relation to Market housing
we've had a lot of discussion previously
um with the developers about affordable
housing but in terms of Market housing
um
in order to meet the requirements of our
strategic housing team you'll know that
we've agreed a form of wording for a
condition that's on page 42 of your
agenda
which seeks to link the provision to the
schmar that's relevant at the time
so that's something again that we've had
confirmation from our strategic housing
team that they're happy with that
very very quickly last thing if you
refer to the table papers
um
we were suggesting originally that there
would be a contribution to a travel plan
originally
that has now changed because I'm advised
by the travel plan team at County that
they prefer to use conditions rather
than
taking a contribution so there would be
no need to include that as part of the
section 106 agreement heads of terms are
unlisted
in my report page 43 so that would be
removed
um I think that's all I possibly need to
say at this stage but
I'll leave you there Tim thank you
thanks very much
Okay so
questions for points of
Clarity on that yes customer
yeah thanks for the presentation a
couple of points the
access point the the southern end of the
site that you say is not within the red
line
um can you confirm that we know access
to that lane
um from the site
you look confused bye
the lane that runs up by the
documents
sorry it's taken so long I'll um
if I show you the connectivity plan
the best thing
sorry has taken so long in terms of the
the access along here
is not proposed to have any access
pedestrian or cycle along there because
it can't it can't be offered
the bottom line it did they don't own
that that access that again it looks
from that drawing as if that access is
included but it's actually drawn so the
access is where my my circle is
and what that is meant to show as I
understand it is the line of a drainage
uh pipe will uh that runs through part
the the bottom of the uh allotment type
so it doesn't actually include that
access so there will be no
formal access if that's the right word
permitted or offered through that space
okay
thanks
yeah
thank you I I think I've got a couple of
questions I'm just going to remember
what they are
um uh is that going is there likely to
be a danger that traffic will use the
spine Road
as a sort of cut through and hence drive
through the Housing State rather than go
down to that mini roundabout and if so
is there to be any traffic management
bumps Narrows or whatever to prevent
traffic using it as a as a cut through
that's my first question the second
question is there is there any
enhancement Improvement or work being
done on the part of path six I think it
is from the spine road to Newton Road
it's currently a public footpath it's
marked on the map but presumably at the
moment it's just like the edge of a
field
um and it probably hasn't got a nice
surface I just wondered if any anything
was being done to improve that section
of the footpath
um on the first one the issue of the
spine Road
um it would provide an alternative route
clearly between
Newton Road and Stowe Upland Road
motorists being motorist muscle one of
them it's the convenience of that route
I don't know about the the issue in
relation to calming and my colleague may
be able to
boys further on that but I would assume
and it's a big assumption I accept if an
alternative route is available people
will will use it if it's as or more
convenient and involves less congestion
I'm not sure that's really answered your
question but I think the options there
um the second thing the footpath would
have to be retained in its current uh
position unless it was proposed or were
proposed to relocate
but we can't actually
advise on what will happen to that
footpath until such time as the reserve
matters application came in because the
design of the development would have to
incorporate the footpath route
in the same way as as has been done on
on the next item which we'll talk about
presumably that will be something that
will be looked at when the reserve
matters comes through on this site
um it will be you know it will be part
of that application what they eventually
do with that part of that footpath which
is obviously it would be a convenient
route for people to get from the estate
on foot down towards town if they're
from that particular part of the estate
that was all I was thinking about but
that would be something that comes
through Reserve Mass yes it would yeah
thank you Council wall boys
thank you chair
um that was a similar question it's
about sort of
impact on Junctions and and it is off
beyond the red line of it uh the first
application where the spine rope comes
out onto Newton Road the next
um
right turn along from that is Spring Row
which again would actually provides a
cut through up to the roundabout and
onto Violet Hill the surgery Park or
wherever
um
at the junction itself isn't it's where
the footpath will where The Pedestrian
Crossing is going to be but
um my question is not specifically about
the junction but really along the um the
roads going through it the the very
narrow there's a lot of
um on on road parking so it's reduced to
a single Lane and there's a level
crossing would that um
my suggestion on that I the highways I
suppose is would that be possible to put
that as access only to prevent traffic
using that as a cut through onto the a
Ubuntu 308
I think that the driver behind the
um
provision of the shared cycle footway
that leads from Newton Road down to
Spring Row
as opposed to originally Pros proposed
footpath
was a recognition that if you use Newton
Road for its entire length down to that
Junction as a cyclist it's a it's a not
a very pleasant environment I haven't
done it myself but I could imagine it
isn't
um
the ability of an alternative route to
provide
safer or more pleasant means of access
for cyclists down to the town center is
something that
I think is possible or the potential is
possible through that alternative route
accepting that perhaps it's not
perfect in terms of the the provision
for cyclists
making that Journey but I think at this
stage we will look at it in terms of is
there an alternative route that may be
usable is this available and can you
know can something be done to to make it
more attractive
to to users of of Cycles so I think in
that term
um we feel that that is something that
could be looked on more favorably than
having to rely on the existing provision
which
well I mean cyclists could still use the
existing provision of course if they so
wish but I think that at least there is
an alternative that that tends to
push them away towards that that
group accepting that I understand the
point you're making about the the
traffic online sorry online on road
parking and everything I would say if
Catherine or Ben want to come in at any
point just um look this way we're happy
to bring you in if you want to add
anything to the question
so I would that that there's second
question is about the other development
onto um starkman Road the where the um
um
the uh the road comes out of the
Scotland Road which is opposite uh well
just up from a junction
onto Stockman Road and some distance
away from the roundabout had a
thought
having that Junction by the roundabout
would have been a better option
moving it up the hill
um well as part of the application for
diapers counts I would I will go through
that in some detail with regard to the
the means of access to the diapers Farm
site because I know that
um there is some disquiet locally and
about where that is proposed to take
place and why hasn't taken place of the
the um
the the roundabout bomb I'm not sure we
need to discuss it under this particular
item we'll bring that that'll be the
next one I will be patient thank you uh
castlewellan
thank you chair I've got several
questions
um what is um could you point out the
route to school from this development to
I believe it's Children's School
um because I'm just a little bit it's a
kilometer
but it's not an easy kilometer on foot
or on cycle
um
um this we're talking about this
particular Point here
um there would be a link through at this
point which will get you onto
this main route here
so that would access onto that road from
that point from that point there that
that's the line between the two sites
but there would be an access point from
there
onto that
public right-of-way
and the alternative would be to
so that so if you're if you're on foot
or if you're on a on a bicycle you've
then got to come around the the mini
roundabout and you may then have to wait
at the level crossing
um yes if you I mean there is a a cycle
as we know the psychopath along this
this route here but um yes that is the
case you would need to do that that's on
the wrong side of the road you probably
wouldn't cross over for that load anyway
um my I just wondered whether some of
the residents might use Cardinals Road
as because that's probably a shorter
route to school from almost any part of
that development so
those people would be using Cardinals
road which we've already said is narrow
with parking sometimes on both sides
um so
by providing the cycle track footway
along part of what I call Cardinals
robot I think you called Spring Road
um
I just wonder if any thought has been
been given and I'm not sure if I can see
it on there as you go into towards you
come off Newton Road
you then come down to
um a fort where Carl was rode with the
terraced housing goes down on the left
and then there's Spring Row we and
Spring Row goes down to the fence
alongside the railway line
and then there's a foot path there I
just wondered whether it's possible to
upgrade
and to include it as a condition were
there any thoughts being given to
upgrading providing a road through
Spring Row and alongside the railway
track
well as I said previously I think that
the the
at this stage what we've considered is
the original proposal was to have a
footpath here this is now shared cycle
route yeah proposed as that
and what happens past that point in
terms of having a set route for cyclists
hasn't been given detailed consideration
I'm not sure we could impose a condition
unless it was something that was
required by the the highway Authority
but I think that
advice I was trying to give was that
there is alternative routes available I
wonder if rather than discuss it at
length now whether we could flag that up
as something to look at I think you can
bring it up with it okay right the next
question is is on page 75 there's a
reference to the
a1120b113 junction and it's a suggested
condition should that be one one one
five it should yes thank you so when we
get to the conditions let's put 1115
here
um
the parking for the allotments
uh is are we just providing uh enough
parking for the cars that were shown
there or are we extending it any any
longer My worry is if some of that could
be on the inside of we're not here to
express the news now it's just points of
clarity yeah
is it just is it just that length
um
The Proposal is to provide and I like
it's not a
clear but this provide
a line of parking there and a line of
parking there
which in total is 18 spaces thank you
that's that was that was the question
thank you very much
thanks um I was very interested to see
the open space on the other side of the
b113 and that raised some questions a
who owns it after the site is occupied
who maintains it and is there any
protection on that land to prevent
development on it
the land is part of the planning
application site
so it's under the ownership or control
of the applicant
because of the constraints presented by
the flood zones
um
conjecture I know but I don't think it's
got much in the way of development
potential
so that beats his role as open space and
also as part of the overall Suds
proposal for the development bearing in
mind that
topographically runs downhill and then
goes down to the river plain
it's not being offered to the council so
all that would be public open space it
would be managed
management agree
rather than being taken on by us
so the purchases of the properties will
be required to maintain that area
so the per the people that buy the
houses will have to contribute to
maintain that space
um the terms of the management agreement
I don't know but um that's my
understanding in terms of how the
overall thing would work right my second
question if I may
um
in the memorandum of understanding a
quote it bear with me if you will
members can be assured regardless of the
relevant which development comes forward
the approved Highway Works will be
delivered a point before the impact on
the highway Network becomes severe
bumping into it no definition of severe
you could make a case that the biggest
impact of this development will be
during the development phase when
they're moving all the vast amounts of
Earth top soil Etc
is there any capability or possibility
that the highway Works can come prior to
the start of development thereby
protecting the neighborhood
chairman yes it might be useful just to
ask Mr Chester to contribute I think
you'll find that chest uh
severe does have some certainty around
it it's it's a word that home Engineers
aren't quite used to and perhaps Ben
might usually contribute to that and
answer your question as we go but just
to
clarify you know severe is not an
ill-designed ill-defined great concept
High Rangers are quite familiar look
forward to hearing definition
hi yeah um
as far as Junction capacity is is
concerned it's when the
Junction reaches it
it passes its
capacity which is a eager up to one
um and when it
reach the point of
past
0.85 it's we weak consider that Junction
to be yeah
capacity and and then anything beyond
that we would generally we
request Improvement
so it's a it's it's um
a point at which the junction modeling
which shows a beyond the
capacity of the junction
my concern really is along the b113
um
large earth-moving trucks you get
informal parking there at the moment
um
small site entrance that I have concerns
along what is a very rural road so those
upgrades I'm sure the people that Park
their vehicles they will be delighted if
they were done prior to all of this
extra
well um
we
agreed on a point of um
occupations mt5 dwellings across the
free
sites that
could um
fund this
um
we'd we would generally find it hard to
uphold and
objection based on
construction traffic because it's not a
permanent impact
so
um
generally speaking we have to
Asar assessment on the
permanent impact upon a junction
opposed to the
construction which is um
considered a temporary impact
and it must come in and that thank you
just to clarify um on page uh 36 we did
advise that we would include reference
to the memorandum of understanding
that's
described in uh in the report we'd
include that as a head of term and when
we come to section 106 should we get
there
um
actually it's not on the list of
obligations we would need to include
that as uh as an emission
thank you casa Morley
thank you
um I wasn't part of the original
committee that deferred this and I'm
just wondering is there a reason why
this application and the following one
were
um
to be determined concurrently is one
application dependent on the other or
they just totally both independent of
each other
each
other
um they relate to the same allocation
but they are independent applications
and
the time the previous application came
to committee it was considered that it
was in a form that it was able to be
presented to committee
whereas the subsequent application
hadn't reached that stage in officers
views so
um
we were able to bring the first one to
committee on that on that basis but as
you have noted that when it came to
committee the first time members were
clear that they wanted them to come
together notwithstanding the fact that
practically you could deal with them
separately
because it's part of the same
application sorry allocation the
approval or rejection of this site has
no bearing or impact on the approval or
rejection of this site has no bearing
upon the subsequent one
no they would need to be looked at
independent yeah
um I've got a question on the a lot
of papers it says that the
status of the allotments is is not
particularly sustainable at the moment
is there any ability to provide water or
fencing along that boundary
help make the allotments a bit more
sustainable
The Proposal before you today doesn't
involve any works
because it's an outline proposal doesn't
provide provide details of any Works
through the allotment site as I said at
the start it is land that is Edge blue
so it's under the ownership of control
of the applicant
that's something potentially I I assume
might be under their control to do so
but it's not something that's proposed
at this stage
okay so we'll move on here's another
questions thank you and so um we now
move on to uh Town Council there's no
one here I understand from the Town
Council
um we have no objector and we have no
supporter
so we'll move on to the agent uh we have
Azure Brooke and Dan bowditch here uh if
you you have three minutes
time here if you put
you could you when you're ready
thank you councilor Hicks
good morning members and thank you for
the opportunity to speak at this
reconvened committee
at the July meeting the application was
deferred whilst Clarity was sought on a
number of matters many of which cross
into the adjoining diapers Farm site the
applicants for both schemes have
subsequently met with officers to
discuss these deferral points and to
assist you with the clarity requested
I know some of these points have been
covered this morning but I just wanted
to reiterate how each of these points
have been dealt with
so in terms of active travel Mr heifer
has presented our connectivity plan
showing The Pedestrian and cycle routes
across the whole allocation at site and
Beyond
main roots are shown alongside the new
spine Road linking Newton Road to the
West with Stow Upland Road to the east
providing onward travel to the existing
cycleway
a new cycle route is also to be created
along Newton Road down to Spring Row and
towards the Town Center thereby avoiding
the southern end of Newton Road
with regards to highways specifically
whilst this application is made in
outline only with internal roads to be
determined at Reserve Mata stage the
applicant understands and accepts that
the council wished to secure a
connection between the two sites
this the applicant agrees to and will be
secured through a section 106 agreement
as per the officer's updated report
in terms of Highway impacts The
Junction's modeled as part of the
assessment identified that the a1120 B
triple one five Stow Upland Road
Junction
um as operating over capacity
a new roundabout is proposed to mitigate
these impacts at this location
accommodating committed and proposed
development traffic with low levels of
queuing And Delay Mr bowditch from PGA
the applicants Highway Consultants is
here today to answer any further
questions you may have on this
turning to open space the master plan
illustrates significant open space
provision across across the site in
excess of that required for this
development with proposed open space at
the northeastern corner of the site
retaining separation between Stone
Market and Scotland in accordance with
the area action plan and the development
brief
finally to ensure that the development
provides a mix of house types sizes and
affordability a condition has been
agreed between parties to ensure that
the housing mix to be secured at the
reserve matter stage will be in
accordance with the latest housing
market assessment for the district
should be noted that the positive
dialogue between the parties of the
adjoining schemes has been occurring
throughout the application consideration
and will continue to do so following the
planning consent in order to facilitate
delivery of the allocation in a
coordinated and managed way
officers have concluded that the
application on this allocated site
Accords with the development plan and
that there are no material
considerations which indicate a decision
should be taken contrary to their
recommendation to approve this scheme
I call on you to recognize the
significant merits of this sustainable
scheme on an allocated site and urge you
to support this proposal and Grant
planning permission thank you
thank you chair just just talking about
drainage in this application we're
dealing with surface water and the sud
schemes aren't we
um yes yes what's for sorry what
specifically are you
questioning yes I
uh sorry
um we're dealing with the surface water
and the sustainable drainage scheme as
opposed to the foul water and
arrangements with Anglia water
I think all of the details they'll be a
more detailed uh I mean assessments have
been provided at this outline stage but
further details will need to be
submitted as part of conditions to look
at that
thank you
okay thank you very much uh right so
we'll move on if no other questions
we'll move on to the uh Ward members now
we have two Ward members here do you
want to go first or second
so here okay so I'll read out from
councilor um David Muller who couldn't
be here today it is long so please bear
with me
um I appreciate this application forms
part of The Stone Market area action
plan and was designated as a suitable
for new homes along with diapers Farm
estate which it joins and I'm pleased to
see there are no plans to build on Zone
one area of the flood plain paragraph
4.2 refers to bus stops located in Stow
Upland Road members should be aware
apart from the very infrequent bus
services uses Newton Road all other bus
services use navigation approach and
Mortimer Road bus services are very
infrequent on these routes also twice a
week on Mondays and Thursdays no bus
service goes up still up and Road
paragraph four two also says it is the
intention of the proposed development
that it may be accessed accessed by
either a new or extended bus service
however although this would be welcome
in reality I can see cannot see it
happening bearing in mind the very poor
bus service currently in operation on
the Cedars Park estate
Newton Road is very narrow and currently
only has a pavement on one side of the
road residents usually park their
vehicles outside their properties making
the road narrower I'm pleased to see the
proposed changes to the road Network
which answers many of the issues raised
by stowmarket Town Council is extremely
important a mitigation strategy for the
junction with Stow Upland Road will be
formulated between SEC highways and the
developers of both sites I noticed
highways England are not objecting to
the scheme I fully support the three
character areas proposed across the site
Main Street a tree-lined spine route
Avenue core and overlap between Main
Street and the green Frontage green
Frontage reflecting the character of the
surrounding landscape and I'm also
pleased to see many of the to see as
many trees as possible will be retained
I support a proposer construction
management plan for the site so the
inconvenience to residents living in
Newton Road is kept to a minimum during
construction I would recommend a
condition ensuring work on the site is
only undertaken between eight and five
Monday to Friday and eight to one on
Saturdays with no work undertaken on
Sundays
I welcome the proposed early years
Center within the site
I do have I do however have some
reservations as follows despite the
proposed seal payments one Cedars Park
Primary School is currently full
to the new Grace cook Academy is also
currently fully subscribed three I
understand Stow Upland primary school is
also full
the results as children will have to
travel further to school which will on
balance of probabilities mean more car
Journeys already on narrow roads causing
further congestion and air pollution
five neither Stow Heath nor comb
surgeries have the capacity for
additional growth resulting from this
proposed development at the present time
the town desperately needs a new Primary
Health Care Facility although I accept
even if one were built there would be a
problem recruiting GPS
Etc no dentists in the town are
currently taking on new NHS patients
to conclude although there are some very
positive aspects of this application by
concerns around school and health
provision and the increased likely
increase in traffic movements resulting
in more air pollution particularly when
the level crossing is closed for trains
to pass I have witnessed considerable
buildup of traffic at the Junctions of
Newton Road and Stow Upland Road
particularly between 8 30 and 9 30 and
again in the afternoon when the barriers
are down it is with regret I do not feel
I can support this application
over to you
the good thing about me and Dave working
closely together we do sing off the same
him sheet so
um
I can't be quite as positive as he as he
physics I still have a number of
concerns
one of them being regarding the axis for
single point of access
all right regardless of a trunk Road
this single parent axis is not going to
be favorable for drivers they're going
to choose to be a single go for a trunk
road which is going to impact on the
parking regime which we currently have
issues with going on a B103
um regards to be pathway which is going
to be adjacent to the curvature of the
axis
being a pedestrian the amount of times
you've been on a Pathways Briar Road and
a car has gone across the pathway I
might have concerns about pedestrians
using it
uh regards to be
well it's a bit it's a bit tiring to see
that we have
ignored some of the part some of the
objections we come across regards
drainage and be current issues we have
there in a report to go is better
uh it is States about to be
drains would be dealt with we're not
having we have no objections from Anglia
water
well kids mentioned about Anglia water
being indeed a severe improvements what
was it to losing 170 milliliters a day
uh currently and also regards the issues
of people living there living around
your development have issues with of a
drainage so we're not talking about
perspective prospective we're talking
about issues now so adding on 300 homes
to the area to ongoing problem
that's not going to make residence fair
living there very happy
uh and also not to mention about how the
Anglia water
how it's currently handling the sewage
going off into our Waters so that's
not able to cope with existing demands
um
let's have a look here
Dave has already mentioned about the
lack of buses I can go I can
expand notes we recently has a
disability Forum meeting where we had
all the bus developers there and we
asked about improvements to the access
to Cedars Park and they are
each one of them said it's not it's not
affordable there's not to be a chance of
expanding the bus routes because they
are not going to make money from it so
wonderful we put more bus bus stops not
so wonder if these bus stops are not
going to be used
uh Dave touched on the schools the open
subscription
well yes we
uh Grace cookman new school already able
to subscribe to her next year
uh the Chilton school which is the
nearest one well they currently are
using external Huts to meet the dance
they do not have the space
we have section 106 money got earned to
go towards the schools
my concern is we're looking at 500 homes
in total for two developments
where we have children already 30
children to a class originally built for
12. water test the xm106 I'm going to do
is goodbye from a lovely shiny shoe horn
to shop more children where are these
children going to go
we're going to have extra people driving
more to get reach out to the schools
going to impact more on the roads
we have section 106 money going towards
primary schools we go to secondary
schools
we have nahu going towards the
um going towards specialist schools
these specialist schools I can tell you
are over subscribed to 2024
how do I know this I'm looking for my
own daughter
so where are we going to get where are
we going to drive these children too if
it's not in the local area
we will provide some driving to the 12
miles
last
great but how's it going to impact the
driving out going to school has in the
packs of a residence
um
somebody want the transport links we've
got there we've already touched on the
dentists which know it no further NHS
patients
um the doctor's surgery
will again
at the moment we have pavement parking
outside it because big car park is
already full
we have a space for five additional
doctors
which we cannot employ these five
additional doctors so already the
doctor's surgery is oversubscribed
we have space for it but we cannot get
the doctors we haven't been out of here
so how where are these people going to
visual elements where are they going to
get treated
where are they going to get to the
dentists where are they going to go to
school
so we have no these local cities but are
not going to be capable to do them so we
have more people driving
we either have them driving on a single
point of access
whichever impact on actually a further
impact spare
or we could have him driving down this
trunk roads which we have parking
pavement Park in the Rio which is going
to be a pro is already a problem
we're looking at the improvements to the
road which we've been touched on Visa
improvements should be done prior to
development because speed severity
impacts to the people who are already
using it we have major issues now
so we are looking at perspective
Hospital aspects of improvements down
the line it's not going to help
residents living here now it's going to
severely impact people living there now
and we are going to have problems for
people once people live on this
development they're going to have
problems in the future so I'm afraid I
just cannot it cannot support this
development
thank you very much
okay any questions for the ward member
before we move on no okay remember so
it's up to us to discuss debate
uh and come to a conclusion we've had
all the information put before us
gave it to us
cancer you're going to kick some thank
you
thank you very much
um yeah I can see the um the
improvements that since the last
application even though I I wasn't there
I think the um connectivity plan the
cycling number
um and pedestrian path on the spine
roads and Improvement
um and the cycle footpath improvements
on the Newton Road
um
the um I find this application quite
um difficult because we're essentially
looking at a large application with a
single point of access in this
application but obviously that changes
with the next application and I find it
I think that um that single point of
access wouldn't be acceptable to me if
this was just the application on its own
but I understand there's other stages to
this
Reserve matters but um I think
I've got to look at that as these both
of these applications at this this point
um
the um
the um yeah I
I think um the access going so close to
Ash's Farm as well was a bit of a
concern
um but I think with the um
it looked like there was better places
than um putting it in by that um listed
building but with the
proximity to the A14
I think that um that sort of dilutes
that impact on the listed building there
um yeah
primary contribution Primary School
contributions it says for a new and
Primary School it sounds like that's
needed from the wards um the the ward
members
accounts from it
um I didn't see anything going to um the
surgery
I don't know if I've missed that in the
papers but it does seem like um there
should be contributions going to the
surgery from this
um with um this amount of houses and put
together I'm um
I'm not ABS I'm not absolutely
um made up on this
um I think it looks to me like there
could be more green space
on this they look they look fairly dense
but I think if we're looking at what's
been solved with this um application I
think um it'd be very hard to say that
it's it's not acceptable so that's where
I am thank you can I just refer you to
page 63 that's where the NHS
correspondences
[Applause]
thank you very much I'll have a read
through that now thanks
on what we saw back in July
um and I really welcome the improved
um permeability for pedestrians and
cyclists the um three meter wide
cycleway along part of Newton Road
um I welcome all of that and I
um
I do take on board the reservations of
the ward members
but there is a bit of a difficulty
because this is an allocated site
and houses will eventually end up on
this site and and what we really need to
be deciding today is is this a suitable
um development to put on this allocated
site unfortunately there are a load of
limitations in stone market we've just
heard from the Ward member about the
schools the doctors the buses now whilst
it's all very well we can allocate some
money from section 106 to go to schools
and doctors we actually have no control
over what the education provider what
the NHS and what the bus companies are
going to do we can't control that
unfortunately
and I know I realize that they are a big
problem since though market and and I
really don't know what we do about buses
because they just seem to be getting
worse and worse and worse
um and yes uh you know it it will end up
unfortunately with more cars on the road
but we're going to get housing here and
what I think we really need to look at
is is this development good enough
to put on that site and I think that
there have been some improvements
um I don't personally live on a housing
estate but I I'm not sure how worried
I'd be about people using the spine Road
as a cut through whilst I appreciate
that that mini roundabout on the triple
one three triple one five Junction is
not ideal
they are the trunk roads and
should should we be doing more to
discourage shall I say drivers from
using the housing estate roads which
might have a load of kids and bikes and
what have you crossing the side roads
and stuff should we be doing more to
discourage them um from using that as a
cut through
um maybe people who've got more
experience of that might might have a
comment to make up but I'm not sure if
that is an issue or not
um so I must admit I am I'm mirroring
towards supporting this application
because
um I think there are a number of
conditions
which hopefully will mitigate some of
the harm the open space on the
floodplain and that's not going to have
houses on is good
um I think that the access Arrangements
off Newton Road because of the Loca the
shape of the site and that location of
the listed Farmhouse make it a little
bit contrived
and it's a bit of a sort of twinkly
access right up close to the A14 but I'm
not sure what else we can do where else
would you put access onto this site
I'm not going to make a new proposal but
I'd like to hear what others have said
but I mean I actually think this is it
is an improvement on what we saw before
and I think it is it certainly
um almost acceptable
um and I'd like to hear what others have
got to say thank you but if you want to
come in
thank you chairman yes um just to answer
councilor cast and the NHS contribution
is the last bullet on page 43 so
hopefully that picks up and I fully
accept we regularly hear issues relating
to surgeries
um and I I fully understand that um we
are I think uh
we must be realistic as to what we can
achieve with an application in these
circumstances there is a contribution
which you've captured and hopefully that
reflects what's sought by the NHS direct
their last bullet on page 43 of the
obligations
um if I can just speak slightly whilst I
have the microphone chairman to the
connectivity and permeability point I
mean following the last committee
meeting
um as Deborah and I met with the
applicants and not talk to some length
with the support of uh Catherine Davis
about the uh cycling and walking links
Cardinals road is not perfect but
speaking as a cyclist having used Newton
Road I find it
a preferable option to an experience on
a b road with traffic in a narrow narrow
narrow Gardens Road does have on-street
parking but one side of that road I by
the power of Google I understand has a
single yellow line which appears
practically to be stopping parking and
therefore to create some more space than
were there simply no control over
parking it also takes you into town
through Crown Street and to the end of
Berry Road and as a route into stone
Market as a cyclist and not a route I
take personally but knowing the roads as
I do I would think that would be
desirable and preferable as a way of
getting from this development as a more
pleasant experience
leave that there
thank you councilman
thanks chair
um I have
reservations about this site
um the sustainability the social aspects
we've already heard about doctors
dentists schools
drainage
anger water chucking thousands of liters
into our Rivers
access
highways it will be right when it's
finished
[Music]
um and I personally have an issue with
large green areas that will be
maintained under a contract for 10 years
and then we're going to have impacts
that some of our council members are
already dealing with with vastly
increased costs but all that is
irrelevant
in the ccg say it's all right among us
some money we can cover it angular water
say don't worry we've got the capacity
highways have approved it and there is a
management contract in place
located site it has improved since last
time so whilst I have personal
reservations I feel that we should
approve it and I'm
pose that we do approve
thank you very much
do I have a second after that at the
stage cancer casting happy to Second
chairman thank you okay we'll continue
the debate uh anyone yep Cancer woman
thank you chair I agree with much of
what's been said already just one or two
other points that I would make and I
think these really
um could be taken up as part of the
reserve matters I I am concerned about
the route to school and I would like
some consideration given to
the use of Spring Row and the foot the
Footwear
alongside the railway line because that
and that leads to Crown Street which
would be a an excellent way into into
town
um much preferable as Mr Mr Isabella
said than Newton Road and Stowe Upland
Road so I would like that looked at I
don't think it will be expensive because
most of the most of the infrastructure
is there it's just a case of making a
few links I think so could that be
looked at I think we have to accept that
the spine Road will be used for through
traffic because of the congestion
particularly when the barrier is down
the congestion around the mini
roundabout and also there is quite a
quite a windy alignment with parking
which brings me on to the um the parking
spaces and the reason I asked about the
number of parking spaces
um for I guess they're not just for the
allotments they are hopefully to reduce
the number of cars parked on Newton Road
itself overnight
um
it's quite a windy road
and it looks to me as if some of those
car parking spaces that are being
provided by way of a lay-by are going to
be on the inside of the bend and there
could be visibility problems as a result
not not huge but
um I guess it's better to have the
spaces there with the with the
visibility restrictions and not have
them at all
um I welcome the memorandum of
understanding I think I think officers
have done a good piece of work there I
think they've taken it as far as they
possibly can
um and the ward members will snow Upland
have spoken with with Bradley and we've
made uh yeah we're we're happy with the
way that has that that is going there's
if I may ask a question it's about The
Pedestrian Crossings could I just check
whether
any of them are going to be zebra
Crossings or anything other than just
dropped curbs I guess that they're just
pedestrian Crossing points rather than
pedestrian Crossings
um yeah I mean it's not ideal
um but it's an allocated site
um it's probably as good as we're going
to get it's better than we might end up
with
um on another day so uh provided
the two the two sites the Ashley's farm
with the type as well
both go ahead and the memorandum of
understanding comes into place to
improve
uh the the only other thing I would add
and that's a concern about construction
traffic
I would hope that even a temporary
access for construction traffic would
not be off Stell Upland Road and
particularly not off the the little
track that's that's between I think it's
a listed building and the former Council
houses uh I I think that any
construction traffic whether it's a
temporary access or permanent access
should be on Newton Road but that's not
ideal
so yeah those are my points
thank you very much
anyone else want to explain I'll have my
word after you Council
thank you chair uh yeah I think back to
support what council Williams just said
particularly with regard to the
condition if we can apply it with regard
to The Pedestrian cycle route down
Spring Road and
possibly along the railway line on to
Cardinal Road providing a an attractive
route as Mrs Israel just said an
attractive route
into town and a safe route and to sort
of try and sort of exclude
through traffic from that area
I do have another concern though and
this is this is this site is 300 houses
plus the additional site and it's going
to have a considerable impact on
infrastructure
Anglia water I've actually said it
currently does not have the capacity to
treat the flows from the development
side to presume it means from the
development site they say they're
obligated to accept the file flows and
elsewhere it says they're producing a uh
an acceptable
way of treatment
um
it's Anglo Waters received considerable
publicity recently regarding uh what it
regards as adequate treatment and what
the public regards as adequate treatment
is it possible to have a condition in
this where we need a more detailed
response from Anglia water that they
will be
um
treating the foul water not just
adequately but in order to prevent
additional discharges I'll bring in
Philip on that and he wants to come in
anyway
thank you Jeff
um I I don't think it would be
reasonable to impose it is beyond the
control of the applicant we haven't done
it uh in other situations to impose a
condition to require some standard of
treatment which we don't have set in
policy so we have advice from anglian
water
um I think to require the applicant to
hold their development Hostage to some
sort of treatment standard to be agreed
with anglian water I I think would be
unreasonable and I wouldn't recommend it
to a committee as a as a point but that
wasn't the comment I was going to make
chairman but I'll if I
would you rather hand back to council
War boys at this point and just carry
that debate on well I think that the
answer is we it's not really in I mean
it's you of course you can propose it
but it it's not really in our gift to
put that pressure on the applicant
because it's nothing really to do with
the applicant did you have a follow-up
at all
unreasonable uh
but it's within the remit of this
committee and the remit of the applicant
yeah
if I made Chapman I mean Mr risperel is
advising you and I reluctantly agree
with him that it's
and one of the legal tests for a
condition is that it's reasonable and I
think Mr espel's advising you it isn't
reasonable so there would be a
a risk of its legality or it being
overturned on appeal
thanks Philip over to you thank you Jim
just
um to ensure we've covered the points I
mean there has been debate about the
nature of the cut of the spine Road um
that was
um baked into the
um development brief for this site it is
an anticipated feature it is expected to
exist I think with traffic carving
measures built into the detail of that
then you know inevitably there will be
some leakage of traffic using it as a
through much as there is on Cedar's Park
itself between
um B13 and the A14 I mean I use that
myself so this does happen and when
realistic but it also creates
um you know it is expected within the
development brief it was anticipated
right at the outset in the allocation in
the area action plan so this is not a
New Concept
can I also follow up on councilor
welland's query about Spring Row Spring
Row appears to terminate the railway
line and then there is a footway running
along the back edge of the houses which
arrives at kills Road
whilst that might be traffic free I'm
not clear how well observed that is and
how safe and secure that would be as a
route for a cyclist moving down there
and and I would probably be inclined to
say that it's six and two threes in
terms of desirability of routing
somewhere I think with cuddles Road you
have forward visibility as you go
and uh you know there are you are
certainly more observed generally within
the public domain so as a safe route
cycling onwards from uh Spring Row my
instinct is that is
desirable and I'm not sure what one
could do about getting from Spring Row
to elsewhere in the town because
Cardinals there is both arrive at the
same crossing point over there
I'll just add my comments I I really
agree with everything that's been that's
been said
um yeah the site is is is a site that's
due to come forward
um we have seen considerable Improvement
there are still some issues on the site
clearly that will never go away but I
think I go back to council Mansell and
Council mayor's point about you know we
were expecting something on the site
have we got the best we can get well
it's it's better than it was and it has
improved and we just need to keep
working with the applicant and when it
comes back to us hopefully we'll see
various things in there that will also
have been taken on board from today's
meeting so I'll be supporting it as well
so I think on that basis it's been
proposed by Council of Mayor and
seconded by councilor Caston just
observing that in the recommendations on
page 44 it should be B triple one five
rather than b triple one three but on
that basis I think we're happy to go to
a vote but Philip you want to come in
thank you Jim yes two small points of of
housekeeping
um
with relation to the second bullet of
the obligations we've got commitment to
a connection to the spine Road I think
what we actually want to see is
commitment to the connectivity plan and
the spine Road
so that's a small tweak to that and I
think that then delivers the the
principles of the connectivity plan and
elsewhere I think I said on page 36
there's reference to the memory
memorandum of understanding being
linked into the section 106 and I don't
think we've that's one of those errors
we've left for members to spot and
um we'd wish to add that as a section
106 commitment to and with those two
points chairman
um
station
that basis we'll go to a vote
thank you chair members that
is that councilor Castle would you like
me to take your vote verbally yes could
I please um vote four please
councilor Willem are you okay or would
you like me to take your vote verbally
I can't get the vote on there but I'm in
favor I'm four thank you
chair that's seven vote score that's
unanimous okay thank you lovely thank
you very much can I thank
um those that joined us for this
application what we'll do is we'll take
a quick literally we'll start again but
five pass by that clock five past eleven
just gets the opportunity for people to
change seats and have a quick Comfort
break thank you very much
foreign
welcome back everyone thank you so we're
going to move on now to the second item
for today's agenda uh which is
dc2103287 uh again uh back to you
Bradley to take us through this
application
thank you chair
um second application we've been asked
to look at this morning members is a
full application
um it's on the adjacent line to the the
area we're just talking about and the
previous application that's known or
refer to it from now on as diapers Farm
confusingly the overall allocation is
known as Ash's Farm but we've divided it
into ashes on the previous application
and diapers on this one as I said it's a
full planning application that seeks
permission for 258 units
this is the wider aerial view map which
again
you'll see
the application site and to the South
Stow market and to the Northeast
snow Upland and obviously the line of
the A14 Trunk Road at the top which is
the other key feature on that
this is a larger scale aerial map aerial
map
um and again you'll note that the the
site butts
the line of the A14 and also Stow Upland
Road and also a butts partially the
cartilages of existing dwellings in this
location here with the remainder of the
open sorry with the remainder of the
boundary a butting Ash's Farm to the
West
um you also know a white area here which
is an an aerial view of the chicken
sheds that formally operated on part of
the site and now
defunct
slim situ
this is the redline application site
the only thing I would point out on this
particular plan to note would be where
the red line is in relation
to the roundabout because that's
pertinent to discussion in relation to
access
this is a constraints map um
few constraints on the site as such in
relation to
um the things you would normally note
but it's adjacent to the built up
boundary which is on the opposite side
of Stow Upland Road the built up
boundary of Stone Market you see the A14
again you'll see the PEC line which is
the blue green pack line which is the
line of the public footpath network
which runs through the site and also
you'll note there are some
listed buildings
in the vicinity
and this extract again you've seen from
the previous presentation is taken from
the development brief the area we're
talking about here is zones 2 and zone
three zone three is a separate Zone
within the development brief which is
drawn around the the chicken the former
chicken sheds and its environs
their environment this is the concept
plan which shows both sites linked
you'll have seen the extract before on
the ashes Farm site be familiar with the
organization space there a similar
approach is taken with regard to
development on
diapers Farm in concept so therefore you
have open space provision top lower
scale or lower density development
nearer the corner
although the northeastern corner of the
site higher density development into
darker colors and the line of the spine
Road
through and you'll also note the line of
the footpath
sorry I should have noted there as well
that the arrows show points of access
and again that's an indication on the
concept plan
this is the site layout that excuse me
um shows the proposed development as I
say it's been it's so full planning
permission uh
just note the the main features on this
one are the means of access to the site
which is off Stow Upland Road by way of
the spine road which
takes up to the boundary with Ash's Farm
there's a second point of emergency
access proposed where you can see my Red
Dot
in addition to the main point of access
so there's there are two points of
access here
there's also proposal within the design
to have a cycle Link at that point
um the general arrangement of open space
is such that the main open space is at
the top of the site
which also includes an area of play it's
an informal landscaped area but it's got
a
an area of play Within it and there's a
secondary area of open space
to the west of the site which links in
with the line of the footpath which is
contained within the open linear space
you can see there other areas of open
space to the South would be contain Suds
features and the nature of the suds
would be that both of those features
would contain
so they would be
um they would contain water year round
so it's important to note that and in
general arrangement of of the um the
built form it's as you can see
um generally perimeter blocks in other
words you have frontages onto main roads
with amenity spaces behind
um there's a Main Avenue of development
through the site
and smaller clusters of development
offer private drives
and the other element I'll point out at
this stage is that the development faces
towards on this side faces towards Stowe
Upland Road
this is again the land sorry this is the
landscape concept plan which um just
indicates the the green provision across
the site and the fact that there is a
degree of linkage between the Green
areas
um not least for wildlife corridors so
in fact you have a smaller landscaped
area
um towards the edge next to the flatted
block and then you'll have a line of
planting hedging leading to the the
larger open space area and continuing
along the boundary and then there would
be a landscape Corridor down this part
leading to The Wider open space
and again you'll see the um the more
formal tree planting indicated along the
spine Road
this is the location of affordable
housing across the site and the mix The
Proposal meets the policy requirement of
35
and it's in a mix of shared ownership
and affordable rented units
um the very recently the Strategic
housing team has agreed the the mix
uh that's shown on that plan
um so in terms of the recommendation as
I've said in the table papers which I'll
go on to that's that's now been amended
to reflect that point
um when the application came in there
was
um
no proposals to add any um
any heating systems apart from gas
boilers through negotiation with the
developer
we've reached a position now where
um
a total of 108 plots in the buff color
would include air source heat pumps as
part of the the first
or would as part of the development and
the um the area in the the blue color
would be a 30
further 35 plots which would have that
provision made in the future
and you can see areas of the affordable
housing provision are included in that
so that covers the whole
the whole
tenure within those particular areas
this is a proposal sorry this player
chose the main vehicular access into the
site the key points to to show you here
are the access itself
um there is a an island that's currently
in position
um
to the left of the main axis proposed
access that is proposed to change or be
altered to a coup a toucan Crossing so
there'd be a provision of a new Crossing
there
and this also shows a provision of a new
bus stop
in this location and you can just about
see the emergency access
point
in the slightly wider area you've got
proposed bus stop being shown at the
south of the site
and also a crossing point
on this um pedestrian crossing point on
this arm of the roundabout
proposed
to the north
this is a connectivity plan within the
site itself which shows the provision of
the main
spine Road and the the secondary roads
leading off of that and also the roots
of the
um cycle paths that would follow through
the site you'll note that the
cycle path shown here uses the root of
the public right-of-way and in order to
do that that would have to be upgraded
to right-of-way status so that's
something that will be captured within
the the means to do so would be captured
within the section 106 agreement as
requested by County
um
there would be a point of access onto
the road here for cyclists adjacent to
the main access cyclists would also have
the opportunity to use
the the point where emergency vehicles
could take access as well and the third
point of access could be
through the existing public right way to
the South which would be upgraded
to Broadway
this is the connectivity plan that you
saw with the previous application as
well just to show the Synergy between
the two sites I won't go through too
much detail in so far as
just reiterating that there are the
three points of access for
um cyclists along here
enter as I said it's a full application
you'll be you're considering so you are
considering details design layout
um this shows typical Street Scenes the
architecture is similar not the same but
similar to architectural approaches
taken on newer developments in the area
particularly relation to Cedar's Park
opposite
um the other thing you will glean from
that slide is the changes in levels the
blue lines you can see
on the plan here
are the Street Scenes that are
interpreted
here so you can see there are some level
changes that the site would need to
um
address as part of the development and
that's that's through the topography
obviously as it sits at the moment
um there is one instance of a
three-story unit which is the flatted
block this would be located
um at the northern Northeastern end of
the site uh adjacent to the roundabout
as I said in the report the design of
that has been varied since the initial
uh submission
um and it's been worked up into a
position where we feel it's an
appropriate location or it's an
appropriate design
that's the floor plan of that building
generally
the buildings follow
a vernacular architectural approach I
know members will have seen this type of
development
on a number of presentations I don't
propose to spend too much time in
relation to this the the the palette of
materials as you'd expect is a is a
mixture of brick render and tile roofs
which again is a pallet that's
um
usually found in this location that is
an example of a two and a half story
building by two and a half stories rooms
in the roof so you see it's Dormer on
the front but generally the buildings
are
two stories with the one example of a
three-story
that's one of the rendered units they've
proposed or developers propose to use
more rendered units along spine Road and
adjacent to Open Spaces as a way of
introducing more character into the
development and and more creation of
space
there's another two and a half story
unit
in terms of the approach to the site
this is the approach coming from Stow
Upland on the B treble one five these
are taken from street view
this approach gets nearer to the
roundabout and I've included that slide
because it gives you an idea of the the
sort of architecture that's on the other
side of the road adjacent to the site
um
this is the actual approach to the
roundabout itself and the site we're
talking about would be
to the right hand side of that that
picture
again that's uh probably a near review
um these were taken a while ago but the
sweep you're about to see is of the land
which is uh again open unused land in
the background there you'll see the
chicken sheds that's again an example of
the architecture on the other side which
does follow a traditional approach
including details um
um that you'd expect to find on that
sort of architecture
um this is a view from the top of the
road
um the northernmost bus stop that I
talked about quickly uh in my
presentation earlier would be roughly in
this position
um this is the site of the emergency
access and I know it's difficult to get
an idea of context overall but it is
taking
um a gap in the original Frontage
um that's a a close-up of the the
chicken sheds which are in situ this is
an approximate position of the um main
access and if I show you unfortunately
it doesn't sweep around far enough but
that point is about where my DOT is
there
this is the access uh the junction
between the b115 and this road which is
also called startup road which is a
rather confusingly
um but the the other thing that you can
see there is the splitter sorry the the
island in the center and that would be
the position of the tuping Crossing
um this is uh views down the road I've
included this one because in in summer
at least you'll note how verdant The
Greenery is on either side of the road
and this proposed certainly the case of
um diapers farm would be retained as
much as possible was one of the key
elements as a development benefit
I mentioned earlier about access being
taken via an excess
public right-of-way which is contained
within a private road which comes out
onto the B treble one five
this is fuse looking up that road this
originally served as it well it serves
as an access to residential development
but also enabled access to the um the
chicken sheds
um and as I say this contains a footpath
so the line of that would be retained
Within
development
um I think that's the end of the
presentation the other things I'd want
to cover off
um at this point are if I refer you to
the table papers
um
at the time the report was drafted we
hadn't had comments back from various
consultees and we've now received those
in the case of the Strategic housing
team as I said in the report in the
presentation they've agreed the the mix
so there is no need now to
um
defer the proposal in order to change
design of dwellings on individual plots
which was the the the way that the
original recommendation to you was set
out in the papers using the confusing
XYZ
um uh reference
so the Strategic housing team have
confirmed there okay the lead local
flood Authority have now said they're
okay the reason for the delay in their
response was that there'd been an
increase in the um in the percentage
except limitation from 40 to 45
and so the developers had to readjust
their Suds proposals to address that
which has now been done sorry the
climate change allowance so that's now
been Incorporated in in information
that's with us so we don't need the lead
local authority to confirmed that
um the sustainability officer has
confirmed that um
he's happy with the approach that's been
taken and suggested a condition
um which we think can be imposed on a
grant Planning Commission
um the noise officer has said that
although they're using airsoft's heat
pumps he needs to know the combined
acoustic impact of the air source heat
bumps and that would be dealt with
through a revised acoustic assessment
so if you were more into mind if you
reminded to accept the recommendation
one of the reasons for deferral would be
to receive that information in a revised
acoustic assessment
um
so on the basis of the above as I said
the the recommendation has been changed
and you'll see part a uh the agreement
that the acoustic assessment and then
Part B follows on as in your original
papers in so far as deferral to secure
the section 106 obligation as set out in
the original report
um and finally
um
I've mentioned in there about the um
there is adequate flow though I know it
was an issue that was raised under the
previous application but under this
proposal angling water have confirmed
that there is adequate flow within the
um
the treatment water recycling center so
the condition is not deemed to be
necessary so again if you if you
reminded to accept the recommendation
that condition would not be appearing on
the decision notice thank you very much
Philip you want to come in
uh thank you chairman yes this is this
is going to be
um
somewhat embarrassing in the sense that
um are we now saying Bradley that we do
not need uh one little a would you give
the XYZ reference which we obviously
intended to refer to specific plots but
um perhaps you can just clarify that so
we're clear what's what's the state of
that element of the section 106
recommendation
yep the the revised recommendation is on
page five of the table papers
um below the bold lettering
where it says on the basis of the above
the recommendation to members is revised
as follows so that is that is the
recommendation you're now being asked to
endorse
uh Jim if I just come back on that and
this is really not how to conduct
officer internal liaison over
applications I mean clearly there are a
number of section 106 remaining in there
but presumably that's that's an
amendment to one is it then
so the item one of the recommendation
becomes what you're proposing on page
five of the
um
item one which is the section 106
introductory then becomes what's what's
written
um in substitution of what's on page 199
is that is that how I understand it
okay thank you well I've got some
questions sir just use as we're into
questions of clarification
um so Bradley a couple of questions so
in terms of uh uh triple parking uh I
can there seems to be a lot in here
uh from what I could see so could you
just take me through how many true how
much triple parking is there
and we know that the triple parking
people then go and find alternative
places to park when they don't triple
Park so where are they expected to park
that's my first question then I've got
something about the affordable housing
afterwards
yes thank you chair
um
having looked at the um the triple
parking provision
um
out of a total of
number of plots 37 are shown as being
triple parking arrangements
so I calculate that as being
14 of the total amount
where there are instances of triple
parking thereof of private drives as
opposed to
main roads
and the organization of visitor spaces
is such that there is visitor spaces
near to the areas where
um triple parking provision is made
how many visitor parking spaces are
there
um it meets I think it's six sorry 100
the 66 in total which meets the um
the requirement
I'll come back to that in debate I'm
sure
um okay and then
um in terms of the affordable housing
blocks there are four that basically
back onto the A14
um what is the height of those so will
someone who lives in the top floor
affordable house be looking at traffic
on the A14 out of their windows
oh
comparison to the
entire
the um the units you can see now are
two-story with the exception of this
building which is three stories so these
are all two-story along here
as well as the uh planting boundary
which would be put along here because of
the acoustic impact of the fencing sorry
of the A14 there will be a three meter
high fence
um
running along there and atop across the
top of the site in order to attenuate
the noise arising from the A14
the houses are orientated so that the
front
facing bedrooms of those dwellings for
example
these ones here would face across that
space to the north so they would be able
to look
if there's a band of three meter sorry
it's a three meter fence you would be
able to look over that
actually those that are on the top floor
of affordable housing are looking at the
traffic on the A14 whenever they're in
their bedrooms yes okay
okay thank you chair I too was going to
ask about the triple parking so thank
you very much for asking that for me I
do have some other queries about the
parking
um you just said that the number of
visitor spaces meets the parking
standards can you tell me if they're
parking over the whole of the site
either just meets or exceeds the
guidance
um
um I'd also like to ask about electric
vehicle charging because it appears that
only some of the properties are going to
be equipped with EV charging and it
looks like all of the affordables do not
so could you just confirm the
um electric vehicle charging spaces and
then if you answer those ones about
parking then I've got another question
I'd like to ask as well
um sorry sorry because I'm just trying
to find a relevant section of my report
because I do mention um car parking
provision
um
mm-hmm
I'm sorry I'm having difficulty finding
at the moment but um in terms of the the
answer
um
the parking provision is in accordance
with
yeah with the the provision in terms of
electric vehicle charging points
um there are on plot proposals where
um units would have their own drives
um but elsewhere
um there's uh proposals to put
um infrastructure to serve some of the
communal plots but not all of them but I
think that as indicated in the papers
the developers indicated or is advised
that
they would be willing to provide
electric vehicle charging points in
accordance with our requirements in any
event and they would be content with a
condition to be imposed on a grant a
planning permission if that was felt
appropriate
thank you so so I presumably went with
our requirements we can impose we have
the ability to impose a condition that
there is electric vehicle infrastructure
provided for all the dwellings
I think that's in your gift yes and my
other questions were are related to the
um access and that we've got a red line
plan for this site we don't have a blue
line plan like we did for the other one
um and just partly out of curiosity and
partly because people have raised the
issue of the access and the roundabout
that bit of land between our red line
and the roundabout at the Toppers to
Upland Road
is that in highways ownership or private
ownership
um I understand it's not in the
ownership of the applicant
who owns it I don't know this is the the
short answer I don't know if my
colleague can answer this highway land I
suspect he is
um
but I understand it's owned by a third
party
and and finally my other question so
we've got uh 108 which are to be heated
by SOS heat pump we've got 35 which
might be that leaves 115 so how are they
being heated
they will be heated conventionally
through the use of gas boilers ISO
Council
thank you very much
um in the contamination report on this
site
um we've got
um a risk of ground gases
um how far have we gone to assess the
risk that um considering there was
chicken sheds on the site that um
animal manure has been stored or
incorporated into the surrounding fields
and the um the risk of having like high
levels of phosphates in the um in the
soil there what what assessment have we
done of that please
um the land contamination officers
relied on the information that's been
provided by the applicant in relation to
ground conditions we haven't
asked for any further information
he's based his recommendation on the
information that is available on site
sorry on on the on the stuff that you've
seen clearly there's an issue in
relation Willis and assumed as a
non-expert in relation to the chicken
sheds because of the previous use and
the quasi-industrial nature of that use
the use on The Wider agricultural land
I'm not sure if that well I don't think
that has been assessed in terms of
potential land contamination but the the
point exists
the risk or the the remediation rests
with the developer in any case so if
there were instances where contamination
was detected that was unknown I think
there is legislation separate to
planning which deals with that as a an
element anyway so there is that
Safeguard and I think that that's picked
up in in some of the consultation
response we've had from the land
contamination officer
okay
thank you just looking at the uh the
density of the housing I wanna is there
a
limit that the um any applicant has to
comply with I know just it's 28.6 and
this
um application 22.6 in the previous one
that um they have to
comply with there's no upper limit in so
far as a density I mean density is
linked to the appropriateness of built
form in a particular location and what
might be an acceptable density in an
urban location clearly wouldn't be
acceptable in a less open situation I
think one of the key elements we have to
bear in mind that as part of the
allocation
um as uplifted by the um
development brief
in brief there is a ceiling on the
amount that you can get there anyway on
the overall site and they've had
everyone has to have cognizance at that
because
um that's gonna that's that's gonna you
know that's gonna up to govern the
amount that you can put on there but
there isn't actually a an upper limit
uh within anything that you know
you know find how they develop
councilman you're next
thank you chair
I've got a question about the main
access point and the splitter iron or
The Pedestrian refuge in that Island
uh
bearing in mind that a lot of pupils use
the cycle track along there
is that splitter Island large enough to
accommodate significant numbers of
students and perhaps parents with prams
and bikes and so on
if not is that something that could be
looked at
it is a concern that the next access
along that goes into the Linden home
site so I wouldn't want us to have a
problem there
I'm hoping my colleague might be able to
address that particular
little island is
wide which is the standard
size the the
I appreciate it's the standard size but
that
I think some well we'll we'll come to it
in debate because I yeah I've obviously
got a view on that
um the approach to the toucan Crossing
will the wearing course be taken up in
an appropriate High skinny resistance
where of course be put onto the
approaches is that proposed
it will be the same changes seven eight
works here
um there are three there are three
points where cyclists could emerge onto
the cycle track alongside
um starkland Road
are they going to be provided with some
sort of barrier to prevent the cyclist
coming out at speed
we we generally don't support the you
use them
batteries on cycle tracks it's not not
be able not across the cycle track yeah
as it approaches the road yeah
because we're in we're in discussion
about another site on the just this very
Point aren't we
um well I'm grateful for that view
um
[Music]
the uh the the flats
are the noise levels at the top floor
because it's part of part of that top
floor that I would guess the bedroom's
out face almost facing the a4t
um
presumably they have been they have been
checked with we don't have any obviously
from the bedrooms you'll see that you'll
see the traffic but when you hear the
traffic
yeah
with regard to that one councilor there
was a noise assessment submitted as part
of the planning application
um where the impact of the A14 was
looked at on the accommodation and in
regard to the ones that there is the
view issue which the chairman mentioned
but also with regard to location and
noise impact the mitigation of that is
through glazing and ventilation the ones
nearest the the A14 yeah that's but that
is what's proposed Yeah Yeah well yeah
thanks
um the rendered units
will the rendering be on all four walls
or is it just a little wrap around at
the front
there are a few units that are shown
having a full rendered front but are the
other three walls surrendered
where render is being used it's a
specific discussion that
logical
in terms of a construction approach and
I think that you'll see from the design
of the buildings that if rendered
buildings are proposed they've rendered
all the way around if elements of the
building are to be rendered like a
particular projection they're rendered
until they meet the main body of the
building so it's a logical yeah so there
are there are some of the units that are
rendered all the way around yes
um are there any Bungalows on the side
um there's a bus service contribution of
231k on page 195.
um presumably somebody has calculated
that figure and
um we do we have an idea who who
ultimately is going to be responsible
which body will be we responsible for
the spending of it and what might it be
spent on
we've been Guided by Suffolk County
highways the public transport of if
that's the correct term in terms of the
amount that is appropriate for this site
and the pro router payment
I'm not sure if you can add any further
on the way that would work then
it was for 500
000
split across the the
besides you
[Music]
passenger transport officer said it will
be um
service improvement so I'm not exactly
sure what that means but I I suspect
it's to fund
um to either
um
our services
now hopefully it will be to to introduce
a bus service to these two developments
or to read
retain a
there's nothing to retake service well
he he he he did speak about putting a
service through the this
spine Road
so dude
yeah at the surface well we can't say
that any further I don't think so thank
you very much those are those are my
questions thank you
thank you councilor Morley then Council
War boys then councilman
so you've got two sectors there
the uh the brown bit which will have
um heat pumps and the purple area which
might which might happen
and it says it's depending
depending on what what is the the timing
issue
um
the drawing does show the two areas
um the Blue Area refers to something
that might that could happen in the
future the drawing actually says
depending on timing or timing
um I'm not entirely clear what the
timing is I've read that there is an
intention to put a second tranche of air
source heat pumps within the buildings
um the developer is here so he may be
able to provide more information on that
and and on the
homes where there is no such designation
what it whose decision is that down to
is that down to the developer or the
purchaser what if the purchaser decides
they want heat pumps and what does my
subsequent question is what does that
mean for the noise calculations that are
being done based just upon that one
okay my understanding would be if you if
you look to purchase a house within the
brown area assuming that that's a bit
we're talking about first you would get
an air source heat pump that would be
within the building constructed that you
buy
um I think in regard to the um
the
the issue of um sorry I've got my second
part of the question was oh it was what
sorry
buildings that aren't designated
currently for heat pumps
whose choice is it yeah I mean I don't
know whether the developer would offer
an option if they're being provided
Elsewhere on the site that's potentially
something that that may be offered I'd
I'd ask the developer when they come up
but in terms of the um I think in any
event you're right the um
environmental health officers
recommendation or his comment does pick
up the fact that there is a noise that's
generated by these by these
installations anyway and I think he
needs to know how that impacts generally
between dwellings on the site and
those on the periphery which are nearest
to the site anyway hence his
recommendation to us
thank you okay next up Council War boys
thank you Chet
um
yes
just to clarify
um
on slide seven the uh this is to do the
roundabout and my initial
question was whether it wouldn't have
been advantageous to have the spinal
Road joining the
b115 at the roundabout rather than
midway between the roundabout and Stow
Upland Road especially as there's now an
emergency access point there as well
um presumably the fact that
bit of land is on
in a third-party ownership
but it's actually shown as part of the
soft Landscaping
on slide seven
sorry cancer that slide seven is a
concept plan
that's not that's not been submitted by
the applicant
um so that's that's just been included
because that's an extract from the
development plan which the council
produced which shows how the site might
be used overall
site eight
sorry slide eight yeah
which is therefore planned
um
this area here is outside of the
development
proposal so there's no proposals to do
anything with that land as part of this
planning application
um but you'll note that the if I show
you site slide nine that might be um
slightly nice it's kind of
um slide a you'll see that in that
corner it's proposed there'll be
additional planting adjacent to the the
flatted development
so we we can't ask them to do anything
on that because it's outside of the
development site but um we've obviously
or there's conditional control can be
imposed on that element of it
um I have a second question uh there's
no provision been made on the site for
photovoltaic arrays on rooftops we've
had some discussion about
SRC pumps and whether they might be
um
the possibility of prospective purchases
choosing that as an option would it be
possible to also put photovoltaic cells
fit them at the initial stage of the
building rather than having to fit the
Retro aggressively afterwards presumably
cheaper for the purchaser to fit it as
the build is being built rather than
have to do it later
yeah
same
in ways the same answer I'll give
councilor morally in terms of what my
understanding is there's a an area that
was shown on that that plan that where
they will be provided as part of the
construction there's an area that they
could be provided as part of a future
and I think and again the developer may
be able to flesh this out but I think
the concern was more to do with
availability or technology in later
phases and how that might change but the
option I assume would be in the gift of
the developer to offer these on more
development or more dwellings throughout
the site as part of the overall
development
but it's not something that's actually
shown on the the plans in front of you
yeah
thank you have one more well just to
clarify that this came up to development
meeting yesterday
where it was asked to develop where it
was asked to put in as a condition that
purchasers could have the option to fit
um
more contemporary forms of heating
rather than
what is is rapidly becoming
all the technology okay we can bring
that up and debate if
um councilman so about you uh sorry
chair there are a couple of other things
I wanted to ask about and I've forgot in
my previous uh previous time
um uh back to parking again
um
is there that there are numerous little
bits of Green Space um including the
attenuation basins and the sort of open
space at the North Area
um is there any plan to put any means of
preventing Carl's parking on the grass
they're like a sort of knee rail or
whatever they're called
the um recommendation would be to agree
a a landscaping scheme there is a
landscaping scheme but a detailed
Landscaping scheme would be more
detailed than the scheme that you've
just had flashed up on the screen there
so as part of that
um I understand the point because it's
cropped up in other developments and I
know the point that's being made I don't
think there's something that we would
have an issue with with securing as part
of a approved lands
landscape thank you and my other
question does relate to the landscape
master plan on slide nine which doesn't
appear to differentiate between
pedestrian past and cycle
shared paths on the they're all the line
of red dots and the blue existing
public footpath I think you mentioned
earlier that part of that was going to
be upgraded to a bridal way so you could
use Cycles on it or something and there
doesn't seem to be any difference on
that master plan is that a problem or
will that be secured but you're detailed
um Landscaping thingy you've just
mentioned
I think that the the landscape master
plan is showing a general concept of how
the the master how the Landscaping would
be treated and on top of that shows
connectivity through the site and the
way you could travel through the site
using non-car modes which is the
indication that's shown on the dots
again with the details that would be
secured through Landscaping Edition
um
we can look at the the details of how
that works but the general formation of
movements across the site would be as
shown on that that plan
because the cycle routes are shown on
that sort of concept
um plan with the purple lines on or
whatever I think what's it called the
concept connectivity plan that we shared
with the other one presumably the ones
that are shown there as cycle routes
will be cycle routes despite the fact
they all look the same on here
apologies are misunderstood yes that is
the case I mean in terms of what we're
trying to achieve here is a Synergy
across the two sites for cycles and
cyclists and pedestrians
um and there'll be an upgrade of that
Network to bridalway status in order to
make sure that they're all fully usable
by cyclists as well as pedestrians
Caswell and bat you thank you yeah that
feeds neatly on to my next question
which is the at the corner of the site
by Upland Court where there is a cycle
route or a route that's going to be
upgraded to Bridal way and links onto
the existing track that previously went
up to the chicken shed
um is there is there any work to be done
to upgrade that private track I mean I
don't know if it would be possible to do
that but it probably isn't suitable for
cyclists at present so is there any
proposal to do that one way or another
whether it's through section 106 or or
by the developer doing some work there
uh and my other question is relating to
the emergency
at the emergency access
what is what is to prevent a vehicle
um using that
if it can be used by the understanding I
had was it could be used by cycle so
it'll be perhaps 2.5 meters wide
but if there is not to be a barrier
then wants to prevent a vehicle just
driving along there
on the excuse me on the first point the
um
I think the track you're referring to
counter is this one here
comes out point on where your dot is now
yeah yeah yeah
in terms of the the way the site is
arranged there's the um attenuation
Basin and next to that you've got the
the track which basically is the line of
the public right-of-way which is not
being altered in terms of the treatment
of that the Landscaping of that will be
dealt with through the condition
um but that would need the agreement of
the public right-of-way team as well of
course because it is a it is a public
right-of-way so they would have they
would be the final Arbiter I think of
how that that particular
track is treated
but it's certainly shown as being
provided next to the open space there to
what standard is that that you've just
run your Red Dot
yeah that is is that 2.5 meters wide so
it can be used by Cyprus is it or is it
just going to be a public footpath
will it if if it's to be used or the
intention is it to be used by cyclists
and pedestrians so the width of that
would have to be appropriate to that use
and there is sufficient room within the
site in order to provide that width
because it's adjacent to the attenuation
Basin so it's not it wouldn't actually
be enclosed by development as such so
that that would be good
um
with regard to the um
emergency access
my understanding is that a Bollard would
be in place to stop cars Vehicles going
in and out at that point there would be
a Bollard to actually restrict vehicles
um but obviously cyclists could pass
through pass by a single Bollard I mean
what what's to prevent a motorcycle
using it
there there is nothing
physically to prevent a motorcycle
um but if you if you put it it measures
to to prevent a motorcycle there's
there's a risk that could also prevents
cyclist because they're yeah they're
they're a similar width so
it's very difficult to thank you
okay right so we're going to move on now
then to the award uh sorry let me just
um
[Applause]
thanks yeah so we're going to move on uh
we've got no no one from the um Town
Council no objection no support we're
not going to move on to the agent uh
we've got Daniel Fletcher and Raymond
long so hand over to you again three
minutes please and we we've got a timer
here thanks very much
thank you Jess sorry it's the greatest
it's David Fletcher I've got uh Daniel
Wilson which might have been the
confusion but um yeah apologies
um yeah the proposals before you today
have been subject to detailed
discussions both prior to and following
the submission of the planning
application with your officers in
particular we'd like to thank officers
over the last couple of months for their
work in facilitating close discussions
between us and the and the developers of
the adjacent site ashes Farmers you've
heard this morning and to ensure a
coordinated approach with the two
applications going to committee on the
same day we've also undertaken detailed
engagement with console t such as the
highway forestry and the lead local
flood Authority
as you've heard earlier we've worked
very closely with the site next door and
we're collectively contributing towards
the world's Junction improvements along
uh
the B triple one five and the a1120
junction contribution towards bus
services and improvements to the bus bus
stop adjacent to the site we've also
given very careful consideration towards
improvements to cycle and pedestrian
connectivity again as you've heard from
your officers
vehicular access I know you've already
discussed has also been considered
carefully
um that the land in that corner of the
site is out outside of our control but
we've chosen a location for the site to
provide the best visibility displays in
and out of the site and a suitable
staggered Junction from the from the
junction to the South
I set out on your offices report the
proposed density of the site is
relatively modest for this location at
20 20 28 dwellings per hectare
post number of dwellings on this site
and the adjacent site fully Accord with
the detailed development brief that was
prepared prepared by by your Council and
it also Accords with the proposed number
of units allocated for the for the
overall site within the emerging local
plan
design and layout of the scheme has also
been subject to extent of Engagement
and the proposed design allowed a sort
to respond to this development brief for
the site
they provide a good mix of market and
affordable housing with with affordable
dwellings pepper potted throughout the
site
the locations of the open space within
the site have also been carefully
considered to provide good access for
residents throughout the site and also
provide important visual nodes along the
primary Street within the development
the applicant's fully recognize the
climate change emergency and a number of
proposals are proposed to maximize
Energy Efficiency of the development
first and foremost we've we this
includes a fabric first approach to the
development and example use of seeking
to minimize energy use of the dwellings
um
and as you've heard we've there's
provision of s or seat pumps
um which overall provides a scheme
that's in excess of the policy
requirements
overall the proposals are considered to
fully Accord for your local plan and we
believe there are no technical reasons
why planning permission should not be
granted today I'm a company I'm
accompanied here today by specialist
transport sustainability Consultants as
long as as well as a member from the
applicants team so very happy to answer
any questions members may have thank you
thank you very much
okay I think we've probably got several
questions so
um could you just confirm uh should I if
I can kick off that's right can you just
confirm in terms of the affordable
housing uh along the A14
um how will those on the top floor Flats
they'll be looking straight out at the
highways passing the traffic passing 24
7. so how will they be able to ventilate
their properties so that they can have
passing out through the bedrooms
so I believe we've got the option for
obviously sort of mechanical ventilation
if we need it but also the ability for
um for residents to to open their open
their windows and as we've heard we've
got as part of The Proposal provision
for acoustic fence along the the North
Boundary of the site to minimize noise
from from the A14
is the acoustic fence not lower than the
windows or the top floor Flats
uh yeah I believe it's it's slightly
lower than the windows in the top floor
flatsy I believe that is correct
so
um can I move on to Triple parking
um looking at the map you've got a large
number of Triple parking right next to
the visitor Bays which means what
happens on all the sites that you will
be very familiar with it always happens
including your sites that people then go
and park in the visitor parking because
they don't triple Park which means
actually the 66 visitor parking will be
less than 30 if people start taking that
option so what would you propose is the
best solution isn't it to remove triple
parking
I think uh you know parking is is always
a I think a difficult issue
um with any site so we've yeah we as
you've heard we have got provision for
for some triple parking
um within the site predominantly to meet
the needs of the the larger
um four bedroom dwellings
um we we would hope and you'd think that
a lot of those four bedroom drillings
wouldn't won't have free free cars
Associated
um
with them um and and secondly I think
they would you know there will be
occasions when visitors will will triple
part because they're visiting uh a house
where they've got
um that existing parking um provision I
think obviously overall our proposals
fully Accord with the the the car
parking
um car parking standards which is which
is which obviously what we've been
working closely with with officers and
Highway Authority on can I just ask a
follow-up then so other developers have
come here and withdrawn all their triple
parking would you do the same on this
site
um that's not something that we um
this point in time I think from our
point of view we have met with the local
Authority we met with the County Council
on our highways consultant is here uh
and they're recommended that we follow
the parking guidance that is prescribed
by the local
are very clear that we have recorded
with that guidance I accept that it's
just other developers have come in we've
drawn all their triple parking so I just
wanted to know if you were up to but
that's your call I totally accept that
and you've met the parking guideline can
I just ask um about solar panels on the
roofs
so can you just clarify who and how
people can get that and how many houses
will or properties will get there
proposal at the moment is that um dot on
any or they're going over and above um
what we actually what actually is
required here we're meeting the um the
planning policy we're all 20 over
um
uh the carbon emissions from building
regulations that's the proposal and uh
well do not need PV pedals at the moment
to achieve that in an all energy
strategy
who are not proposing PV panels
throughout not not at the moment and if
they if they are required then or they
will obviously we're looking they're not
suitable orientations that nothing is so
required can you just explain required
by who
if they're if they are building
um billing regulations requirement then
that's something that we'd have to
Accord with at that point in time if the
regulations change as things stand we
are providing above the policy
requirement in terms of energy and
that's something that we have put
forward today in terms of the
presentation I know a lot of the members
have questions about the two areas in
terms of the brown area and the purple
area in terms of that was put forward in
the screen earlier by by Brad and we
just want to be very clear that we're
going above the policy requirement when
it comes to energy and that's why we
have committed as a developer to the
area in purple that's what we are going
to be delivering
um in terms of air source heat pumps and
that's above the policy and therefore
the area that is in um so there in brown
is what we've committed to they're in
purple is something that we will look at
um potentially delivering depending on
if regulations change at that point in
time and also the supply chain I accept
what you say and I'm going to say the
same thing we've had other developers
have come in here and said they're going
to do the whole thing with their Source
heat pump be way above minimum policy so
it's just we just need to get to get
that Clarity we meet every two weeks and
we have developers in here every two
weeks
um okay open it up to other members who
want to follow up further questions
Council Morley your first
the the areas that
I think it was 155 odd houses that
aren't designated for heat pumps
will the occupants or the purchases have
the ability to specify
heat pumps in those properties
I didn't hear the question clearly is um
I'm not sure if you want to repeat mom
or chair
the 155 houses
that are
for the 155 houses that are not
designated for heat pumps
do the purchases potential purchases
have the option of specifying that they
would like heat pumps not at this point
in time
um not at this point in time
um the I think all we're looking at it
is that they are very specified rules
and regulations in terms of policies and
building regulations in terms of what we
are required to do in our point of view
we've gone above that recognizing that
there is a climate emergency and we have
chosen as a business to deliver I think
it's in excess of 20
um of Airsoft heat pumps on the site to
provide that for future residents so
those have been decided that it's been
decided that that would be um on the era
in in brown and here in probably
something we will consider in the future
for the remainder of the site it will be
conventional gas
now Samantha uh thank you um on that
point about the conventional gas heated
homes
um is there I mean will there be any
um sort of uh
come the time when gas is no longer
available uh will the whatever fittings
are in those dwellings be compatible
with moving forward in the future will
that be completely up to the owners to
fund any transition to a different
heating Arrangement or is it going to be
sort of back compatible
my understanding is that we're building
these homes to be adaptable for the
future and as and when those regulations
come in then as a developer that's
responsible that we've signed up to the
chart and all the rest of that we will
have to ensure that we are according to
whatever the rules and regulations are
at that point in time I can't really say
what that will be at this stage because
we don't know what that is but Our
intention is to Accord with that when
that comes into place
can I just come back on that so so
um when the purchaser buys the property
yet they they can use gas heating I was
thinking about when it comes to the time
that they have to completely refit their
heating that's that cost will be all
down to them your your system
um will be defunct whatever you've put
in there because you're only working to
what is what is required now
I'm not really sure if I can answer that
in in Fuller detail because we will have
to Accord with whatever the regulations
State at a point in time so I think
there is a charter that is that it's
been considered by government now in
terms of
um when when it's no longer relevant to
have gas that developers potentially
will be contributing to that happening
at that point in time but the details of
that are still to be determined so we
can't sit here at this point in time and
commit to that until we know what the
rules and regulations are but what I can
say is that whenever the rules and
regulations change we will be complying
with that
Council Willem
thank you chair I've got two different
questions one is leading on from the
discussion about air source Heating
if um PV panels or air source heating
are requested by a purchaser
uh would there be a need to alter the
internal layout to accommodate the the
kit that's needed
or can it just be would it just be a
straightforward we'll take that room out
and it will be
will be the housing for the heating
system or will you need to have a
different layout for that particular
house
with installation of PV panels also um
you can retrofit that also in in and
it's something an occupier can do on the
on their own free well today if they
choose to do so in the future
and um
you you would need to inverter for that
and then it's possible to work with it
not a problem
yeah I I understand that the quest the
question really is but I can ask it in a
different way
if you've got a one of the houses that
has
air source heating provided
do you have a similar layout house
but without airsource heating or do or
is it a particular layout of the house
because it has air source Heating
it's a similar layout but down to your
question thank you that's that's great
thank you the other question is is I'm
returning to The Pedestrian Refuge so
it's a quest for the highway engineer
if if there are platoons of cyclists
coming up the cycle track which we know
that they are and pedestrians and so and
when people with prams and so on because
that's a very busy cycle chain that
you're you're going to have to cross
can the
is it possible to redesign The Junction
with a larger pedestrian Refuge to
accommodate
say six or eight people who are got
halfway across the junction have to wait
before they get the second up I fear
that without that it's an accident
waiting to happen people are going to be
half part way across and the Island's
not going to be big enough for them
I'll give you a question
um the designs that you've seen on the
slides presented by Mr heifer
um have been updated and the island has
got a little bit bigger than what's been
presented the idea is that if the button
is pressed on the side that it is a
straight across Crossing it is not a
point where you would stop halfway there
is a refuge Island in there to enable a
pole to be mounted the idea is that
people would walk across the entire
length or width of store Upland Road in
one go now this is the cro sorry
um I'll I'll first wasn't clear it's
it's where the
um it's your main spine wrote out
is there a there isn't a a a crossing of
any sort other than drop curves are
there across there no there is it's a
controlled toucan Crossing in between
upper spine Road in between the uh spine
Road that's being presented for the
access and the existing star Upland Road
which is the estate road on the opposite
side
now I think I think you still
misunderstood or or I have do you mean
across the Bell mouth of the access
right I see what you mean uh so that is
designed in accordance with the relevant
design manual for rows and bridges and
accommodates cyclist width
um this is obviously a full application
and that design has been presented and
is suitable for that amount of people
that can be Crossing at that point is
the right width and that's the inexact
accordance with the relevant design
standards for an access I understand
that but so what is the right amount of
people then you said it's big enough for
the right amount of people is the right
amount of people 10 16 2 1
I'm pretty sure obviously we can't
exactly know how many people will cross
at any one point on every single day can
we so it's it's a case of that that is
in accordance with the design standards
presented uh and highways have approved
that design approach it will be Road
Safety audited and go through the
relevant section 278 design approval
process so we will be checked again at
that detailed design stage and
independently Road Safety audited so at
that point should the auditor is a
professional in that
decide that that Island needs to be a
little bit bigger than what's been
presented currently at that point it
will then be redesigned to meet those
requirements and do you think that will
come up at stage one safety audience no
stage two stage one has been assessed
and it wasn't brought up at that stage
but you had counts of pedestrian you had
you had a pedestrian count
when you designed that you knew how many
how many pedestrians are likely to be
going along there oh no we do not want
to take each pedestrian count as we were
not required at that time that you might
be for stage two if that's what was
requested by the highway Authority and
the road safety audit person that would
be undertaking that assessment at that
time thank you
thank you councilman
sorry Jews done dealt with my uh
any other questions at all
no okay thank you so we'll move on to
the uh Ward members
um should I do as last time go first on
behalf of
okay
okay oh yeah thank you
um as with the previous application we
actually did have objections from a Town
Council which are in the notes and being
substitutes I'm not sure if you had time
to read through us
the
objection from the Town Council is a
lengthy one
uh I'm not going to read through it but
it's still very valid
we have heard from a developer that they
have met with us yes met with us
took away what we said
change the name in pencil and gave us
back the same application
none of this who actually meets
recommendations from the Town Council is
not fitting with what the town needs
there's mentioned about the density if
it have concerns about density from a
low Town Council
we've mentioned again before angling
water have said very Okay but well what
angry and water say Obviously we have to
say a word for it but okay so there's
concerns there
uh there's concerns regarding the access
yes we have heard that this is not in
the developers hands
we haven't seen the conversations
between who owns Spa access but it could
be made a safer access onto a
roundabouts we're not sure but we don't
know what has gone on between here
but we know that this would be a better
axis but it's not on a plans it's not
looked up because it's not owned
uh the site layouts we we had to be
earlier
site out layouts with a green area and a
center which would have been more
beneficial seeing it from a road access
you'd have wouldn't have had a just face
onto houses it would have had more it
would have more screening it would have
had more Community feeling but we've
lost that
um
some Consultants would be issues with
climate change West we have around the
vs also here pumps I like those that is
that's one good thing about it
but from what we heard now there's less
commitment especially if you have purple
it's if the change if this changes
wouldn't it be better to have right now
have
commitment but we would
in both areas where we are actually
looking for meeting for climate group
crisis where we have other developments
doing further
uh
uh we have the town councilors mentioned
about the sustain the 22 percent
uh achievement targets yes uh local
Services issues regard buses World bus
stop brilliant again we've already heard
from the bus
communities these buses will not be
provided
so we're gonna have a bus stop which
will not be provided
it will have a pass-up of an a bus to
come to it would be nice to look at just
like I've done this we have in the area
where we have bus stops not being
serviced
uh
uh so we've had lovely engagement we're
not being listened to we've had
not been not feeling that it's got any
commitments to actually meet with the
area with what actually it could be
integrated into the area we resigned a
house is going to be available could be
done better
uh
so I don't have to mention about the
lack of a lack of amenities that's not
not today
I don't have to mention well I've
already mentioned but the Town Council
have given a name for the objection
the Town Council has not been listened
to remotely regarding the out of the
application of this
and as an award member I have to second
with what the uh Town Council have
recommended
are we getting what is best for the area
are we getting the best housing layout
uh even if we have looked at
and I do have a concern as a resident of
a council house having these areas where
we would be looking at the A14
yes we've looked at the sounds but have
we looked at sound from that height the
sound does change from there and we all
have wind actually able to access open
windows
but the air quality coming from the A14
into these windows
we are going to we have the option of
opening window and breathing exhaust
fumes or having a window closed
so
oh no
there's some things I like but it's not
going far enough
this isn't an outline thing this is a
black and white this is what we all get
this is a wishy-washy going we may look
at it if policies change but
we need to be looking for the future we
need to be looking for residents and are
we going far enough and I have to argue
that this is not the best
this is not the best plan for what we
could get this is not what we should be
looking at now
thank you very much
I'll just read out councilor Muller's
um comments and take if anyone has any
questions at the end
many of my concerns with this
application are the same as my concerns
with the previous application I agree
with the comments made by Stone Market
Town Council who object to the
application engagement by the applicant
has been poor and could have been a lot
better the minor amendments made by the
applicant with regards to housing units
and parking fail to address the
substantive issues raised previously in
respect to poor access to the site
prominence of public immunity space poor
design in the buildings and lack of
architectural Merit of the scheme
particular concerns the possible
disturbance of the surface of the former
chicken farm which could release stored
carbon into the atmosphere tree planting
should be strengthened to offset the
carbon footprint When developing the
site I fully support a proposed
condition regarding this part of the
site
residents are very concerned about the
increase in traffic along Stow up and
Road and Newton Road it would have been
better if the access to the site would
have come off the roundabout located at
the top of Stow Upland Road however I
understand a covenant prevents this the
proposed access halfway up Stow Upland
Road is unsatisfactory
shared foot cycleway on the west of Stow
Upland Road will be significantly
inhibited by the creation of the new
access halfway down the hill
the cycle connection at the southern end
is welcomed but a connection to the
North End needs improving and I do not
support the proposed toucan Crossing
the allowance for parking is inadequate
there does not appear to be good sight
lines between the man
sorry between the many homes and their
allocated parking spaces which would
potentially lead to a high level of
on-street parking as many parking spaces
may be deemed unsafe
any triple Deck Parking should be
avoided
I'd like to see the use of air source
heat pumps electric vehicle charging
points and solar panels considered where
possible bearing in mind the climate
emergency we're currently facing
a construction management plan is also
essential and please refer to my
comments on the adjoining Ash's farm
development and I I am unable to support
this application
so that's from the Ward members yes
customer do you have a question for the
ward member I do have a question because
councilor Muller's um words mentioned
some Covenant that prevented
um access to the roundabout and I just
wondered
um if the planning officer could
Enlighten us a bit about whether or the
or the highways officer Phillips waved
his hands I think you can come in uh
thank you Jim well I'm not sure planning
office I think Bradley answered that
question sort of but actually I will be
inclined to ask the applicants to answer
that one
they probably know better than we do am
I allowed to ask
prevent preventing access while
um unfortunately I don't have the answer
to that this particular juncture but I
I'm happy to go away and come back and
confirm I don't have it right here right
now sorry
any other questions for the ward member
no okay so it's up that's it folks we've
had all the information put before us
it's for us to discuss debate and come
to a conclusion
councilman first off uh thank you chair
um whilst I fully appreciate that that
we're going to get housing on this site
it's an allocated site
um I don't like this um design of this
development there are lots of things
that are are inadequate or just meet
requirements you know it it ticks all
the boxes it's meeting policy but I
would like something better
um I'm I'm baffled as to why you'd want
to put a three-story building
adjacent to the A14
um where the fence isn't going to go
high enough because those people who
live on the top floor if they do open
their windows they're going to get a
load of fumes a load of noise
um and it just seems and it's at the top
of the hill so it's going to be really
prominent I just think that's an odd
place to put a three-story building
um I I I'm not sure if there was
anything about air quality
um assessments either in the in the
report I'm sorry if there wasn't I
missed it
um uh there are a significant number of
uh uh instances of triple parking
um and I think um mid-suffolk planning
committees are becoming a bit notorious
on on um having a good old moan about
triple parking
um and we we've already heard that that
in the um stowmarket area action plan
this site and the adjacent site that
we've just been contemplating earlier
this morning
um had an allocation of 400 I know
that's gone up
um but it's now up whatever it was 500
and something
um in total over the whole site
um so maybe it maybe it might be better
to have slightly fewer on this site and
therefore we can get we could get rid of
the trip instance of triple parking
um and put a little bit more space
around so there was room for for
non-triple parking and still meet or
exceed uh would be even better uh um the
parking standards
um uh I think the um
the the
whatever it was the map with the brown
and the purple things about the air
source heat pumps okay so it exceeds the
20 requirement for
um carbon-free heating systems but again
um it's like a sort of sop to Let's tick
the Box we've done it we've we've got
our requirement of air source heat pumps
you know why not offer it to
um prospective purchases as an option on
all the other dwellings
um let them decide whether they want to
buy a house which currently has a gas
boiler and they know they're going to
have to uh Fork out um some money in
future to convert it to a a more 21st
century form of heating
um
so um uh yeah and I I'm I'm also a bit
concerned about this access point
um I would like to know more about
whether how much exploratory work has
been done about making the access off
that roundabout it would make so much
more sense to have the access on a
roundabout
um that's that psychopath besides
Scotland Road is it's quite a steep hill
for Suffolk I know it's not much for
hell of you if you're used to cycling in
the in the in the mountainous parts of
the country but for Suffolk it's a big
hill and if you're going down the hill
you'll be going a a good old Lake down
that hill and now you've got to stop
halfway down
um for the access point if you're coming
up the hill you're going to lose
momentum every time you get to that
Junction and and you're right I think
the the points that were made by
councilor wellum uh about the the number
of people who use that route there is an
extensive developments going on up the
hill in Scotland and this is the most
convenient route for those people to
walk or cycle from their developments in
Stockland down to the station and the
center of town it is a busy
um uh cycle way and we're now making it
more uh difficult for people to use
um the fact that the um design of the
crossing of the access road hasn't taken
into account the fact that there is a
large volume of pedestrians and cyclists
on that path I think more could have
been done there
um so I'm sorry but I can't support this
I think um improvements could be made to
this development to make it more
acceptable thank you
thank you yes
yes councilman boys
uh I think at this point I must say
um
but um
these arguments uh of two
ideas here which have are in conflict
and they shouldn't be
the first idea is about we we should
we're responsible for creating the best
possible design spaces for our present
and future communities
and the second is my
attitude towards building regulations is
that building regulations are about a
minimum requirement and not a ceiling on
what is possible
um at the very least in this situation I
think future
for future occupants of these houses
that's probably going to be the most
important purchase they have they make
in their lives and they should have the
opportunity to Future proof that
purchase as much as possible so they
should have the opportunity to
adopt new technology that will allow for
that
um
my second concern is the egress of this
spinal Road
onto the um b115
uh I'm not sure whether the two can
cross it is a solution
um where we were discussing
Crossings further along at Scotland
there were huge concerns raised about
tailbacks from such a Crossing that is a
busy road I think
uh
you know there should be more
sensitivity towards the current users of
that road and I think the egress of the
new development on spinal Road needs to
be thought up
um
the um Covenant over there that's been
appears to be preventing access onto the
roundabout
I think should have been or could have
been explored in more detail
um before that the possibility of
exiting onto the roundabout was
dismissed
so I'm not feeling very confident about
supporting this as the best development
on this site
thank you very much
speaker I'll comment yeah cancer
thank you very much um
a few things um
joining on to the roundabout
for me is a bit of a worry because um I
think you then create a really easy
route down to Berry Road on the other
side um
a a cut through and I don't think that
roads suitable for a cut through okay
not been on the roundabout doesn't stop
it from happening but it doesn't make it
quite such an obvious direction to go in
um
yeah the layout of this is
there's a lot of things I don't like
about it I don't like the XXX parking I
don't like to see affordable houses on
the side of the A14 it's um
it's the the one of the few houses where
you don't get a choice whether you live
there or not you um you're putting
probably the worst position on the whole
site
um I've I've seen lots of these
applications though that are similar I I
don't think that's a um a good enough
reason to say no to this application I
don't think that would um stand up and
appeal but it is it's not nice to see
um
the um
so um this land contamination issue that
I I talked about earlier in questions
um
I think that um I think the potential
contamination of this site being an AMX
livestock farm and potentially um
storing manure on site for years and
years means that there is a there's a
risk to water quality
um in groundwater becoming polluted and
I don't feel like at the moment we've
done enough to make sure that that um
risk isn't there before the um as an
authority
a condition I'd like to see is that we
have a a large a um much more
um
relevant assessment of the soil
contamination risk on the site before
the um before the um plannings agreed
um we um we look we're talking about
Anglia water connecting to the um to the
sites and the potential of um effluent
going out of when they haven't got
capacity but having the groundwater with
phosphates in is going to be much much
of a much bigger pollution risk than
them that connection so for me I think
that would be quite important but um
where yeah I'd like to also see the
commitment to off-plan houses being
offered
airsoft or whatever low carbon um he
something away from gas I think um the
ones being built with gas boilers all
the radiators as far as I understand all
the radiators would have to be changed
when they went over to air source heat
pumps which um the pipes might be in the
right place but it's going to be a big
cost and it's a cost that um will
definitely have to be um paid by their
people buying them because they won't be
able to carry on with the gas thing
um so for me
that there's lots of bits in here that I
don't like but I haven't really I'll
listen to debate and unless I hear
something that I think is something we
could really um
take to um
to appeal and stand by I think I'd be
voting for this
Philip you want to come in
yes thank you Jim yes I mean it has
occurred to me the when the poultry
question became
was mentioned earlier
um that it would be possible to include
that if you don't page 201
fourth bullet up from in the list of
conditions and and I that basically
looks at grass um
gas contamination from ground gases and
I would say you'd include for analysis
of former poultry uses so
um accepting that there is a former
chicken site here
um I would say that that's certainly
within scope to amend a a condition over
if members chose to go down that route
and clearly there's a lot of debate
around that
um
councilman talked about the possibility
of cyclists hearing down the hill I
think
go again with my own experience of
cycling both up and down it
um if you look on page 307 you've got a
fairly clear impression of where the
access point lies relative to gradients
um my own Instinct because you're not
quite the point where you achieved
escape velocity
um and and you certainly won't be doing
that on the way up the hill
um uh page 300 600 307 you have two
plans of the access point with the
Contour
um and I don't know Brad if you've got
the uh development brief but the
development brief and getting back to
the roundabout and I don't know who owns
that piece of land it seems to me you're
looking at what I would classically call
a ransom strip frame
um and the development brief in the uh
itself acknowledged that that wasn't
going to be an access point and I don't
know Brad that's it's quite resistant
what am I doing I should direct you to
the papers on page
301 there are two big red arrows which
indicate the access points into this
allocation that's not an application
plan that's the development brief so it
was always expected that somewhere up
this
hit an entrance route into the
and obviously you know that's a that's a
concept plan it doesn't tell you any of
the detail and what you have is a little
further downhill but it's still the same
concept I guess in terms of
country and access
I think for the moment chair I'll I'll
leave it there we've obviously been here
before committee and we've had deferrals
to negotiate whether developers are
willing to increase the content of
Renewables within their schemes I'm
listening listening to the break Channel
that was going to be my next question
for you is
um we've been in this position before uh
where we've been discussing and we've
that was the same we're all saying the
same things pretty much on design we're
not happy with the overall designs some
of the layout isn't right inadequate
parking although just meeting the
standards I accept that not quite up to
the environmental credentials that we
expect in mid-suffolk we expect I think
probably we'd be fair to say more than
this
and so you know what we've done in the
past is we've asked it to be deferred
for officers to go away and try and push
the developer in this case Crest
Nicholson to come back with a better
plan
quite frankly that's the way I feel now
already but I'm very happy for others to
come in and make a proposal on what you
feel we should do or if you want to just
go to a yes no of course that's also
your decision so
Council mayor you are next and then
Council well thanks Jay I I support your
position
um I'm not going to go move all of the
state sustainability access issues have
already been discussed for me it all
comes down to design is this design good
enough
or turning out on his head is this
design poor enough for us to reject this
application and I sit between the two so
I think a deferral route
is fair to all
I don't believe 37 triple parking spaces
is good enough even if it is meets the
minimum standard
um
so yeah I would support your
recommendation or suggestion
I will propose a differ on the basis
that um
officers go away and try and improve the
design
that's the weather next
uh thank you chair that gives me the
opportunity to second that proposal
which I'm pleased to do
um just a couple of points that I would
make um
perhaps to to look at if if the deferral
is successful
um like like a number of others I don't
understand the reason for the toucan
Crossing there is a toucan Crossing just
to the north side of the roundabout and
I don't understand why one is proposed
with that particular location if one is
required somewhere
on the sort of south side then is that
that is that where is where it needs to
be I don't
I don't think so the other thing I'm
concerned about the houses and the flats
that are so close to the A14
particularly
around ventilation for the top floor of
the flats
um the other thing that I I'm also
um concerned about is that if people
were to look at page 299
um it shows the edge of snow Upland as
it was not as it is but as it was
um
I think can we get that up on the screen
at all please
um
oh it's a different
that note well it's post two line now
it's the one that shows
that's it yeah thank you
um there we can see the edge of Stow
Upland as it was
um and we can see the A14 and we can see
a gap between thorny Green Road
and the A14 and it was it was
anticipated that those that those fields
there that Gap would remain and there
would be no there'd be no sort of
bringing together of Stow Upland and
Stone Market because there would be a
green space there unfortunately
those fields are now being built on
permission was given for development on
those fields and one of the reasons that
it was thought to be acceptable
was because the Green Space could be
retained on the south side
in other words the area where the flats
are proposed and so on was to remain as
a green space to protect the gap between
Star Upland and Stone Market so we've
lost it on the North side we're now
looking to lose it on the South Side so
basically all there is between
developments on the two sides is the A14
Bridge so
that's that's not a good thing I think
there should be the the
um developed area should be moved away
from the A14 particularly around the
roundabout and where the flats are
um and I think that's something I would
like to be looked at as part of the the
further work if if the deferment is
agreed thank you okay what I'm going to
do is go to a vote then on a proposal of
deferral uh chairman yes and I please
ask if you're going to ask me to
negotiate something I do need well I'm
all certainty about that yeah so I think
the design and layout self-explanatory
around the design with the uh two-story
properties overlooking the A14 so that
the residents there and the affordable
housing when they open their windows are
looking out straight onto the highway
and the impact that might have
well there's two and three
there's both
um so the the layout of the therefore
the layout of the site
I've got inadequate parking uh has come
up and we know from our experience what
happens in sites where we have triple
parking
uh poor environmental credentials I
would say
um you know we're doing the minimum but
we like to think that
that proud of our sights in mid-suffolk
so can we go further than just getting
over the basic line
um we've then talked about the transport
and the the the points that cancer cast
has made around the chickens and the
impact of that and then around the
highways cycle concerns that have
brought up
brought up the main things
and whether or not the two can is an
asset or whether it's uh just a you know
an another disruption to flow of traffic
and I'd ask I know the clock's always
ticking on these things we're very happy
for it to come back in you know four
weeks as soon as I know there's work
pressures on Bradley but you know we
don't want this to delay your
application we just feel we could give
it a give it a better shot
foreign
just trying to capture chairman so I've
got
um good design and layout aspects
including two and three story proposed
units adjacent to the A14 adequacy of
parking including removal of triple
parking potential for purchases of PVS
or state other improvements above
minimum standards and and then I was
typing whilst you're talking Gem and I
missed the the tail end of what you were
suggesting as a shopping list of items
to discuss
we've had discussions around the impact
of the cycling so just to be really just
to come back and make sure what's being
said is accurate is you know we're 100
comfortable with and then the two
couldn't Crossing let's see
um
yeah the The Pedestrian refuge on the on
the junction yeah
yeah that was to do
yeah please so chairman um clearly the
second is agreement but defer for
officers to negotiate good design in
layout aspects including two and three
story opposed units Jason 3014 advocacy
of parking including removal of triple
parking potential for purchaser PV SRC
pump other improvements above minimum
standards cycle and refuge consideration
and token Crossing appropriateness uh
and for officers to report back to
committee
that's been proposed by councilman
seconded by Council well and are you
both happy with that
okay so on that basis we'll go to a vote
please
thank you members that vote has now been
updated and is in progress
thank you members chair that's six votes
for deferral councilor Morley has left
the meeting thank you thank you very
much okay so final item on the agenda is
site inspections do we have any site
inspection requests that need to be
reported to the committee okay so I
closed the meeting at 12 50. thank you
very much everyone